at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday night time once again for the
main show yep pokey's tearing the carpet
up in the background
she's been running around she knows when
the show starts and she tries to she's
like
you guys need to pay attention to me
you're just talking to these lights
yeah she doesn't have a concept of an
audience or anything yeah I mean you
know cats don't understand internet
that we know telecommunications no they
don't know
Zach says so this operation was named
after what I do in bed every night yeah
well
I will say that it was named after what
certain people did in bed every night
yeah so you know what I mean this is
part of the MK Ultra thing that was
going on yeah now we did do a show about
MK Ultra a while back but I don't think
that we got into this specific
um the specific details of this
particular we mentioned it sub project
like I don't I think we mentioned it but
I don't know if we got too much into it
and you know it's not really that big I
don't even remember what we talked about
on the MK Ultra show we might like cover
some of the same ground but
it's not really that big a deal you know
what I mean
um Camp guy said we are feeding a stray
cat that's been hanging around here our
regular cat is getting very old so we
will try to tame this one and get the
vet to inspect wow
that's so cute
I always when I was growing up I mean
you know we we got Pookie from a family
friend but who found her when she was a
baby kitten but um when I was growing up
our family always had cats but we never
actually went out and like
bought a cat or like got a cat they
always just kind of like wandered up and
adopted us you know what I mean yeah you
just find cats you just or they find you
yeah pretty much I mean that was how it
always happened when I was growing up
yeah uh somebody's tequila says loving
the hair tonight Jenny thank you yeah
this is one of my favorite wigs I think
my favorite one's the blue one but I
think this is probably my second
favorite
and I thought it was good because it
matches my Dario Argento shirt you know
what I mean got a whole red oh yeah yeah
remember yeah it has chains that go on
it too but it's like I didn't put the
chains on because I just had it in the
laundry so it didn't have chains on it
um
uh Zach says I always want I always
wanted a cat still do but uh mom is
allergic
okay that sucks I don't know what I
would do if I couldn't have cats I love
kitties
and uh you know so what's everybody
doing this evening I'm trying to like
everybody's still coming in ease into
the [__] because I'm kind of sleepy as
usual yeah it may not be that long
tonight we'll see well the good thing
about this topic is that you actually
know a bit about this as well yeah
and uh as [__] up as it is it is kind
of
funny in a [__] up way I mean it's not
funny but
I don't know some of the details of it
are just outlandish you know what I mean
like some of the [__] that they do
wouldn't think government should be
interested in this
but this is the intelligence agencies
and
um they don't see the world the same way
you do they're looking for super weapons
and the best weapon you could ever have
as a mind control
and they were trying to find out a bunch
of different ways to control people's
minds
so you can have the best weapons in the
world
but if you [__]
if you don't control the mind of the
enemy and if you don't make people
accept the victory that you've achieved
they'll just fight on forever and no one
will think you actually won
you know unless you damn conduct a
genocide and just kill everybody there
then people will definitely know that
you won but that's not what they wanted
they wanted to resolve conflicts using
mind control and then controlling people
through mind control
including the American population
so uh that's the Ultimate Weapon It's
better than atomic bombs or whatever if
you can control people's minds that's
that's the Holy Grail
and get them to agree to things you
never have to go to force
um you can kill themselves destroy
themselves you can get them to do
anything
so that's what this is about and uh
they looked at a bunch of different ways
to do it drugs or just blackmail uh sex
operatives all what the hell is what is
that noise what is she trying to get
into something
so this is part of uh of them trying to
figure out the best way to do it now
during operation paper clip after World
War II when
the U.S military industrial complex and
the intelligence agencies absorbed all
of Germany's stuff for Germany's best
scientists they found out a lot about
mind control and uh and other dastardly
intelligence tricks you said dastardly
dastardly yeah oh they're [__]
dastard that's one of my favorite words
yeah they're very different
Spooks man that's what they're called
Spooks they're Dastardly and they got a
bunch of different ways of doing [__]
and um
you can trace it all back to the [__]
Pinkerton detective agencies and stuff
the 1800s two things specifically about
operation midnight Climax and maybe MK
Ultra as a whole
one I feel like
um if the goals that they were trying to
achieve were indeed the goals that
um that they were actually trying to
achieve and it wasn't just some cover
story
um I feel like they didn't really
succeed in what they were trying to do
and two I have a sneaking suspicion that
specifically operation midnight climax
was maybe
um one guy's like perversions and him
just like using taxpayer money to fund
those perversions allegedly that's kind
of how I feel about it it because it
does seem like
I don't know we'll get into it but it's
just I I feel like the guy that was
running it uh you know the guy that was
kind of put in charge of it
some of the [__] that they went I was
like that dude is just kind of like
getting off on that I don't really think
he thinks he's like
experiment or like solving any problems
or anything like that I just had a
feeling
well I think they wanted did want to
know what the effects of LSD what you
could do with LSD well sure yeah they
had all kind of different like
experiments they wanted to know what LSD
did to a person in a damn compromising
situation involving basically
using them uh getting sexual dirt on
people you know they wanted to figure
out how they could use what was effect
what was effective and what wasn't
effective now I'm sure dude enjoyed his
work because he was able to watch
hookers screw dudes all night long
basically
[__] I don't know what the hookers
look like did you dig out what they look
like no they don't there's not really a
lot of well I have to say the um a lot
of the MK Ultra I think it was mostly
one hooker wasn't it no no it was more
than one okay but they didn't really say
how many it was well like I said a lot
of the records of this have been uh
destroyed
um some of it has survived I think about
a thousand pages of it like a little
over a thousand pages but they didn't
really they seem to have not kept track
of the sex workers that they used or the
people that they experimented on which
seems kind of unsigned random random
jobs it was just rant yeah so if you
lived in the San Francisco area or in
New York City around the Times these
experiments were going on and you happen
to go to a brothel
um you may have unwittingly been dosed
with LSD like that and hot all kind of
crazy [__] just knowing the way knowing
the way that those guys would operate
they would just consider this to be kind
of like
uh [__] field expedient knowledge it
wouldn't really be all that scientific
about it this is not a sign they
absolutely were this is just they wanted
to just try it out to see if it worked
and what was and they were experimenting
on different ways to apply this and what
do you tell a dude you know what do you
get the hooker to say and they're just
trying to see what was possible you know
so it's not going to be a scientific
deal it's an ex it's a weapons
experiment basically you got to look at
it that way I mean they were basically
just throwing everything at the wall to
see what's so stuck right pretty much
they didn't really have yeah they had
some nebulous goals I guess uh in terms
of like you said mind control getting
people to uh do things like Manchurian
Candidate type of [__] getting people to
um do things that they wouldn't normally
do see if you could talk them into like
getting them to forget things that kind
of [__] so they did have those kind of
goals but it's like it doesn't seem like
they were super scientific in the way
they went about it they were just kind
of like trying it out trying different
things out like to see what worked and
what didn't that can sometimes yield
quicker results than an actual
scientific controls though you know what
I mean just follow your instincts use
your you
artistic about it see if you can get it
to work and then afterwards maybe they
would try something more scientific to
prove that it worked but it was just an
experiment
yeah
um but you know the reason what they
getting people to forget things like
she's talking about that's you know
clearing out memories that could be very
useful if somebody found out something
that was compromising to you
and you really couldn't kill that person
maybe you could erase that memory yeah
they were like operatives that were
retiring and things like that that had a
lot of sensitive information they knew
like they wanted to be able to erase
their money yeah stuff as well and then
uh what if say for instance
um
you get a guy
and he's part of a
a threat organization maybe a a a
company that you don't like you don't
like what it's doing or a government you
don't like what it's doing
you get a hold of him
uh do a bunch of [__] up [__] to him
and get him to become multiple
personality to have multiple personality
disorder one of them is his normal
personality and the other one is an
assassin personality that you put in
there he sent him back to his
organization he destroys his own
organization
and then he takes the blame for it and
it's totally untraceable to you that's a
bunch of [__] like that that was that's
about a Manchurian Candidate was yeah
um so it would be useful stuff or you
get you get a hold of an enemy and you
just break his mind you know and uh
he's now submitted to you he'll tell you
anything brainwashing you know then you
actually swing him over to your side
that kind of [__]
that's what they wanted
or you just [__] get dirt on a dude
and you operate him on remote control
and you send him back to where he comes
from and [__] up his own organizations
and give by giving faulty commands and
running the place into the ground and
he's got to obey you because if you
don't you'll release all that dirt you
got on him that's what Scientology did
but Intel agencies do that yeah it's all
the same kind of [__]
uh Zach says what Tom just described to
make an awesome thriller story I think
I'm gonna steal that sorry Jenny no no
that's that's just right out of the book
yeah this has been calling from for over
100 years well like I said there have
already been several stories
particularly in the 70s I feel like
after uh stuff about MK Ultra has
started to come out
um I think that's kind of why in the 70s
you had like all those political
Thrillers like yeah uh what what was the
one that we just watched the other day
wasn't man sharing a candidate it was um
[__] now I can't remember
the average civilian can't comprehend
this kind of stuff they don't think that
it's real it's something out of a movie
or something fantasy something never
happens
the reason why they think that is
because the average person is atomized
they have friends and family that's
about it but they're not part of a of a
network or an organization that kills
people and are willing to die for what
they believe in that's just an alien
concept to them
Cults are like that militaries are like
that that's the way I was I was kind of
raised that way to be infantry from the
[__] military academies when all that
[__] started
to the average person that'd be a
conspiracy theory no people don't work
together in concert people don't use
teamwork people don't lie yeah they do
it's just that you don't
but this shit's been going on since the
1800s look at the Pinkerton detective
agency that was really where the CIA
was was kind of a copy of a private
detective agency back in the 1800s and
it used ex-cops x x criminals ex-hookers
it did everything for strike braking
um [__] up elections
um
eliminating the government enemies
they did all kinds of shits right there
on [__] Wikipedia all right
and it'll give you a basic Lowdown of
everything that the pinkertons really
originally did well that's Child's Play
compared to the [__] that they do now
uh now in other countries it's well
known but you know like [__] the
saddam's agencies would do and what the
KGB would do and just other Israeli
intelligence you know they did [__]
wild [__] too
but you never hear much about CIA it's
just kind of like rumors black budget
stuff drug smuggling [__] human
trafficking and weird stories like that
and you think oh that America would
never do that yeah America would never
do that but a CIA would
their mission statement is [__] Wild
Man and Arcana Rogue
that's why JFK wanted to get rid of him
which might have been why he [__] got
taken out well yeah and I think um in
the 1970s like the late 1970s after all
the [__] about MK Ultra came out like
the media exposed it and everything like
that I think Edward Kennedy was one of
the ones that uh did the Congressional
investigation into it because obviously
the CIA are like overstepping their
bounds and doing all of these unethical
experiments yeah so they did bring in
like some new laws that were supposedly
to you know you can't do experiments on
unwitting subjects which is what they
were doing during MK Ultra I don't know
if that made a goddamn bit of difference
or not but I'm sure I've made everybody
feel better that they had I wouldn't
trust those dudes I would never trust
those dudes
you know I think just chances are
because America is such badass and it's
done [__] over the past [__] since
World War II that's come out that is so
[__] Wild
that it that was true it really did
happen I would never trust those dudes
because that's not really America it's
just an agency of dudes that do whatever
the [__] they want probably a lot of it
just to line their own Pockets or to
help their friends end up in certain key
positions in the government they
probably run the show in most other
countries eventually the intelligence
agencies run the government because they
have all the dirt on everybody that's
how Stalin got into power
uh he came up through the through their
version of Intel I think it was I forgot
what an nkvd or some I don't remember
which it was it was like their version
of the CIA
I don't
that's where Saddam Hussein he took over
a rock he was ahead of their version of
the CIA
so they probably run the show
it's
big Tech works with them or did a lot of
them Google's part of it
yeah
oh people don't that's a that's a
conspiracy theory people don't use
teamwork [__]
101st Airborne Division is 40 000
Killers all working together
but we were in public we're a
conventional Army we wore uniforms
intelligence ages don't do that they lie
cheat steal break laws anything to get
their admission done and then what their
mission is is kind of Cloudy and
nebulous
it's not for you to know
it's probably something bad
Zach says speaking of have you guys ever
done a show on Watergate we have not but
I just wrote it down because that would
actually make a good show uh as well
yeah we probably should do a show about
that one of these days so
um so let's even we already did a show
about MK Ultra but I do kind of um want
to get a little bit into the background
of it
um just in case you didn't see the other
show or because I don't even remember
what we talked about on the other show
so MK Ultra actually started in 1953.
and it was around this time period okay
so I think that there had been kind of
like worry about you know brainwashing
concerns
prior to like probably like after World
War II because I kind of feel like
um you know people in the American
government were thinking oh the Russians
and the Chinese and stuff like you know
the Communists were
like way ahead in their brainwashing
technology because I think that people
thought well that's the reason that so
many people believe in the Communist
ideology is because they have all these
people brainwashed so I think that there
was a perception
uh you know post World War II I guess
like in going into the 50s that
that the Russians and the Chinese must
have some really badass brainwashing
techniques to get all these people to
believe this now I think the thing
though that sparked
MK Ultra in particular
was uh the pows from the Korean War
who were basically because it was kind
of like a big deal when they came out
and they were saying oh you know the
Koreans are not so bad and all this
other kind of stuff like they had been
brainwashed or they'd been like forced
to say certain things and everybody was
like really freaked out about this
and I think that was kind of the impetus
because whoever like in the CIA you know
in the government they were like look
it's like obviously all of these
countries like Russia China Korea they
are way ahead in this whole mind control
thing and we need to jump on that train
because they're like way ahead of us
were they no probably not but that was
the perception so they were like well we
really need to start like a program and
start experimenting with different kinds
of mind control and see what it is
they're doing and see if we can best
them in it let me amend a little bit
what you said
ah
they were seeing these guys come back
out of that Korean situation like how
the [__] did they do that
the Communists were ahead of us in mind
control techniques but the thing is is
that we thought they were doing things
like drugs that they were using secret
serums yeah weird weird kind of like
medical procedures that's not what they
were doing we were so far behind we
didn't understand it really what they
were doing is kind of like
guilt-tripping them pretty much the way
a cult does
there's a basically a how-to manual and
there they didn't originated it actually
originated from the Nazis the Nazis and
the and and the commies during the
Marxist period
during World War II before a little bit
how how the after the Bolsheviks took
over Russia and same thing with the with
the German national socialists they knew
their their intelligence agencies that
they started to form new about this too
but there's a Dutch Rider who has a
whole book on it that you can read that
you can listen to the audiobook on on
YouTube it's called rape of the mind and
it's it's from like 1954 and I listened
to this [__] it's fascinating
and it's my control is
about breaking down somebody's will
most of his talking to the person
it's not torture per se it's kind of
like persuasion and guilt tripping and
endlessly talking to them and then sleep
deprivation
and eventually you just wear them out
and they start agreeing with you
you know they're using logic and reason
too
so it's not some wild [__] it's more
like a sales technique they just keep
drumming it into your head over and over
again until you believe it
it was actually quite simple repetition
is like one of the main things
but if you listen to that listen to that
audiobook rape of the mind it's on
YouTube you'll immediately recognize it
it's what
it's what uh basic government propaganda
news propaganda you uses it all the time
in advertising campaigns
if they're putting in memes memetic
weapons and uh tropes that has a lot to
do with it
guilt and self-doubt those are the main
things that they do the smarter a person
is the easier it is to brainwash them
because they're conscientious
kind of the more
dumb a person is the harder they are
to brainwash or more willful a person is
you know especially if they're kind of
like uh anti-social real hard to
brainwash them
unless they want the brainwashing
because they want to they can gain from
the ideas they'll do that too
but you so they were ahead but they
weren't ahead the way the CIA thought
they were ahead they thought they were
using [__] drugs to do it well
because the CIA Under the Umbrella of MK
Ultra they didn't just experiment with
drugs they experiment with electroshock
therapy they experiment with straight up
torture sensory deprivation yeah all
that kind of [__]
um so anything they were looking for
truth serums they were like I said they
were looking for [__] that would
basically like replace your personality
with another person like they want to be
able to wipe your personality and like
insert a new one yeah that wanted to do
that like I said get people to like
forget certain things so they could
um you know white people's memories like
after particular events yeah it turns
out all that stuff even sodium pentathol
which is known as like the main truth
serum you can resist it
especially if you're a trained agent it
never really worked as well were they as
they thought they never really found a
good truth serum they never really found
anything that could wipe someone's
personality or they would find some [__]
that would [__] you up and you know give
you some lingering trauma and [__] but
it's like they never really found
anything that achieved what they wanted
to achieve the best truth serum is
alcohol
true yeah and they've admitted that yeah
and alcohol and confidence you get real
chummy with the guy and get drunk with
them and just let him relax and you get
get to know each other go [__] it [__]
the interrogation man we we know you
didn't do it let's go get a drink
all right so they start building the
guy's confidence and you get him drunk
and eventually he's drunk he'll tell you
anything he'll tell you he'll tell you
the truth too yeah because he's drinking
and you're his buddy you're a drinking
buddy well because drinking takes away
your inhibitions it takes away your
um
you know it takes away it's like the the
little part of your brain that says hey
maybe I shouldn't say that yeah
usually they play in with the guy's ego
tell them how great he is right How
brave he is and [__] how good it's gonna
be when he goes home you know but I read
a couple but I read a really great book
that came out several years ago that was
just called brainwashed and it was just
like about all those kinds of techniques
and stuff and the guy
one of the guys were that said that they
were experimenting with all these
different things and it's like trying to
find a truth serum and all the drugs
that they experimented with and they
found out found out the same thing in
the end they said alcohol was the it's
not 100 effective
um either but it's like it was way
better than any of the other [__] they
tried alcohol and pumping the guy up and
being nice to him is most effective when
it comes to getting truth out of
somebody yeah
um because he starts let me tell you
what really happened they're like that
you know what I mean [__] eventually
get you become friends with them but
that's what real brainwashing is is
becoming friends with you okay
and getting you to swing to their side
you know uh
and that's what kind of okay like you
guys know that you know I served in
Korea I was on DMZ
[__] Camp Greaves first in the 506
Infantry
and uh I know the Koreans real well and
then later on I was able to find out a
lot more about North Korea once I left
because I was in a high security Zone I
don't know what they told me
um
when they were saying that the North
Koreans were good people they weren't
lying Koreans are nice people they're I
would even the North Koreans if you
listen to what they say I would
in general say that their Koreans are
kind of sweet really
um
so they're not lying they they were nice
uh and the chances are the Koreans
knew they were doing a head job on them
but they probably thought they were
doing it for like well for their own
purposes to make them look good in the
world stage but they believe their own
[__] because everybody in North
Korea believes they believes the state
[__] they believe it to be true
just like in a cult
just like saving a person like when
Christians get a whole person and save
them you know from their sins and [__]
that's what they did to those dudes
Leslie says uh the Banshee chapter is a
very good movie yes it is I actually saw
it probably about a year ago
um it was recommended to me by somebody
and yeah if you haven't seen it it's
really really good
um but yeah now just because I said that
they are sweet and they're kind of
acting like they're saving it doesn't
mean they didn't punish them or torture
them they did that too
but that was still almost that's like
everything that's like a normal military
situation you miss you you misbehave
you're in prison you're in A POW Camp
you misbehave they'll punish you but if
you go along with their [__] they reward
you then they start praising you so
that's how they brainwashed them
Zach says speaking of Korea I saw a
video on that director of the Kim's
kidnap to make movies for them yeah that
would make an awesome that it's it's
actually a decent movie if you haven't
seen it I think it's called youngery
wouldn't it yeah youngery yeah yeah yeah
sorry yeah it was like a Kaiju okay kind
of like a Godzilla movie it was good
yeah I want that [__] sorry like a
big happy he's a cool looking monster
like a two foot tall when you put it
next to Gojira yeah
they could have him fight yeah why
doesn't somebody make that movie
nowadays that would be pretty cool
actually Godzilla versus Pulga sorry
yeah yeah
I mean I'm surprised they have it or
maybe they have but I just don't think
the Japanese would think it was funny no
probably not it's probably not funny to
them I guess but you know it's just
monster movies so I'm not gonna get like
he's not copyrighted
True North Koreans didn't copyright him
yeah
yeah yeah okay bring it but it's better
looking than uh uh then some iterations
of Gojira yeah yeah he's better looking
than Gojira I think he's too I think
he's like kind of cool looking well
because some of the Godzilla movies like
some of them Godzilla looks really cool
and then some of me look like kind of
stupid you know what I mean looked a bit
like [__] the Crouch it's his name
the guy that came out of the garbage
Oscar Oscar the Grouch the way you look
like Sesame Street Christina asked gonna
grouch and [__]
and what was the little blue one Grover
Grover yeah
yeah he did kind of he kind of did kind
of look like a muppet somebody like a
muppet yeah
but uh but yeah so how many MK Ultra
projects sub projects were there nobody
really knows
um they think it was somewhere between
140 and 170 different sub projects like
I said they were all basically concerned
with different aspects of Mind Control
not all of them were a lot of them did
use utilize drugs but um you know some
of them utilized other things as well
like you said like sensory deprivation
or electroshock therapy or other things
like that
um so they were all trying to like do
some different [__] oh [__] damn ghost
knocking [__] over there no it was it
was falling down before that I saw it
get rid of that method
well I only just put them up there like
because I didn't have a frame that was
that size because that poster is like an
odd size so I don't have a frame that it
that fits in there
um John Gore said yeah they softened
Godzilla's image in the 60s and 70s yeah
I noticed that and he looked kind of
like not
I don't know I didn't really like the
look of Godzilla from that time so
pogosari actually looked like a lot
cooler he looked kind of more stylized
which I was kind of more into but it's a
decent movie though if you haven't seen
it like you probably see it on YouTube I
think that's where we watched it didn't
we watch it on you on YouTube what movie
polka sorry YouTube yeah it's free
it's not copyrighted what are they gonna
do yeah it says pukus sorry but they
call him pugosario
to the whole movie
yelling at him and it's taken place in
the Korean medieval period it's not it's
not in modern cities
but yeah if you didn't know what Zach is
referring to is that uh the Kim's
actually did kidnap because he wanted to
make he really loved making movies and
so he actually kidnapped the director
and the actor right and the actors the
director and the director's wife that's
right
to make the movie for him yeah make the
movie for him then they let him go
eventually
I think didn't one of them die in
captivity though I'm not really sure I
have to look up because I remember when
we were kind of reading about that and
it's like when I was reading about that
movie like I remember here but I don't
remember like what the outcome of it was
because I was just like that's some
crazy [__] you can make that [__] up
Zach said Jenny you ever thought of
writing a political thriller type story
I'd be so into that one of my favorite
subgenres
um I don't know it's never say never
it's you know it's not one of my
favorite you know uh subgenres to write
about but you know I I like them so I
might be able to now she's [__] with
Spock and he's like swaying back and
forth good okay be good but yeah stop
trying to get him from trying to get
attention she's like I'm a kitty that's
what I do
so so yeah so out of the somewhere
between uh-oh pokey's on yeah hi Pokey
I'm still mad that that poster felt like
that it's always falling down though
especially when the Fan's on look at her
being chill
so you know so somewhere between the 140
170 sub-projects of MK Ultra was the one
that was sub-project 42 known as
operation midnight climax probably like
I said the funniest one not so funny for
the people that it happened to
but you know what I mean and as I
mentioned uh almost all of the what else
you know almost all of the MK Ultra
records were destroyed because in the
70s when [__] started leaking out about
it because you know make no mistake like
the dudes that were doing this [__] they
were very aware that this [__] was super
unethical and that if the public found
out about it they would be really mad it
was illegal too right yeah and a lot of
it was also illegal yeah so they were
under no Illusions about that kind of
[__] so as soon as like [__] started to
leak out like in the media and stuff
they're like I think it would probably
be a good idea if we like destroyed all
of these records because we're gonna get
in big [__] trouble guarantee we
don't we don't know even the [__]
half of it we probably don't
um this isn't the good stuff they had
real good stuff okay again it's all and
I mean even the [__] that leaked out is
bad enough so you can imagine like what
the [__] else was going on you know what
I'm saying probably [__] having to do
with [__] orphaned children
orphanages in the [__] well now they
do know
um because that was among some of the
papers that leaked out they do know not
so much operation midnight climax
obviously but um some of the other MK
Ultra projects yeah they did
um experiment on vulnerable populations
sometimes that was Prisoners sometimes
that was orphans in orphanages
sometimes it was the mentally ill or the
homeless or you know anybody that
wouldn't really be able to protest all
that much or wouldn't be missed if they
disappeared or something like that well
evidently during the reason why I
brought up orphans
during Operation Paperclip when some of
the uh German
intelligence agents got absorbed in they
had some secret mind control techniques
that they were using for you know kind
of like gestapo type stuff that they
were doing right and what they would do
is they would go into a
into orphanages and grab a bunch of
pretty little girls or boys or whatever
and turn them into sex operatives
and send them after guys
they did something to them to make them
uh aggressive
and they would get these the target to
have sex with them but then they would
also get pictures of it
and then once the kid did his mission
and everything they the Gestapo would
[__] approach the Target and say look
we got pictures you with that little
girl all right if you don't want this to
hit the press or your wife to find out
about it
you know you better do exactly as we say
and then you can run that [__]
on remote control well what if he's a a
politician
somebody who's elected you need him to
vote a certain way or what if he's a
captain of industry and you want to
control his industry
that's how you do it
well it all could have been it all could
have been fine if he just kept his dick
in his pants but yeah
kind of human weakness no they'll seek
out any kind of human weakness well see
thing is is that you do that with a an
adult woman the guy was oh [__] it I
don't care if my wife knows you know
right she could do that well yeah it has
to be something right like and illegal
or yeah you can do it you could do it
the gay action uh that would would that
wouldn't have worked in Germany because
they were doing all that gay stuff back
in the 30s they were open about all that
a lot of those Nazis were that way like
Ernst Rome he was openly gay a lot of
people don't know that that the Nazis
were a there's a gay military man's club
when it first started with the SA they
got replaced with the SS though but you
couldn't use homosexuality as dirt on a
German
so the German intelligence agency is the
only thing you could use is dirt on them
Pito stuff so that's what they used and
I mean that still does work now yeah and
so and gay stuff would work here in the
50s yeah it would work here in the 50s
they did do it do it yeah they did do it
but that went out of style you couldn't
you couldn't really hurt anybody with
that well yeah nowadays you can now it's
just going to be yeah yeah because
that's pretty that's always going to be
right so it's like so evidently what the
Germans were doing is they were taking
him this is I don't know how much this
is true this is
because this is what other people who
who supposedly know the subject have
quoted the sources
they would take those children from the
German
um orphanages
and they had kind of like psychologists
abusing them and torturing them
enforcing multiple personality disorder
into them and then when it had the
multiple personalities the multiples
they would train them each multiple to
have a different role
one of them might be an assassin the
other one might be a spy
the other one is the little girl the
other one is the Aged
so they could get that kid to switch
through these different personality
modes
I don't know what they did with them
maybe they killed him when they were
done with them you know he's this is
[__] Bad Dudes you know
I always kind of wonder how effective
that was though because we've done shows
about multiple personality disorder or
dissociative identity disorders they
call it nowadays and it's like there's
not even really a consensus in the
scientific community over whether it
actually actually exists or not yeah and
I just I find it doubtful that you'd be
able to
induce it on purpose at least you know
in a controlled sort of way like the
kind of [__] that you're talking about
well there might be a failure rate and a
success rate the ones that fail that
kill those the ones that succeed because
it's already very very rare anyway like
usually when it happens it has to do
with um sexual abuse yeah and they were
trying to induce or like some kind of
like horrible job yeah they were trying
to induce it through sexual abuse they
were keeping them in cages and [__]
that's evidently what the sources said
this was happening in Germany in the 30s
40s too
um it was part of the German internal
security networks
evidently and evidently the CIA was
interested in it and got a hold of that
technology and Operation Paperclip
that's what is being said
wild [__] it may be true
um
I can't vouch for it didn't see it
it wasn't there a long time ago
but um yeah you might be able to force
multiples to a certain extent and if
you're real ruthless and there's no
paperwork on these kids they don't have
any families or anything the ones that
fail you can just kill them you just
keep the ones that are good and then
they might be good for a couple missions
then you kill them when you're done with
them
I mean that's kind of like an animal
breeding program that's what they do
when they're trying to breed animals you
know I mean well these are the good dogs
these dogs here we don't want those
genes kill those puppies we'll keep
we'll keep breeding these puppies
I mean you'd have to be [__] in him
super inhumane but the Nazis were known
for being pretty [__] cold-blooded I
mean they had death camps yeah you think
so they might have done that yeah they
were kind of known for that pretty
cold-blooded you know
it's one of the many things that they
were known for you know not everybody
knows this but they're not yeah we're
kind of bad guys
but and so you would it kind of sucked
so you would say that well their
intelligence agencies must have been
[__] super ruthless
um
so yeah I think I think I think there's
some truth to that well amid to say too
that and and I'm not saying that
everybody would succumb to this because
everyone's different
but certain types of people if they are
put in a situation where this is their
job or they're threatened with various
things if they don't do their job yeah
like going into a camp right or
something like that then they will uh
become desensitized and they'll do the
[__] pretty I don't know if they're ever
gonna enjoy it some people will if
they're [__] up but I do think you can
get probably more people than we're
comfortable thinking about yeah
um to do that kind of [__] if you and
also if you kind of like ease them into
it yeah they're gonna say it was for
National Security it's for the war yeah
or if you give them like a good like a
noble intention these kids have no
future anyway they they they're never
going to make it
um that's what they would think they'd
rationalize it now here's something else
that we've done other shows on it they
found girls
that seem to be from East Germany back
in the 50s who were some kind of sex
operatives that had been killed remember
like the lady spies who knows maybe that
were those little girls from that
program grown up
yeah I mean man it started at eight
and then by the time they were 20 they
were on some other Mission they got
killed or killed themselves the ones
with the clothes were stripped the tags
and you know you're not sure what did
she die of smoke inhalation you know she
had a like it's all women like it's all
women and she had a pistol we're not
really sure where she got that pistol
she was doing something in this hotel
room
that that may have been where those
girls came from they might have been
recruited from them German
orphanages and part of their
intelligence community
she might have been a sex operative from
an early age well they know she was some
kind of operative because she had like a
whole bunch of wigs and uh passports and
all kind of crazy yeah so you know she
might have been a lifelong member
started at eight
yeah there's no way enough yeah no way
you know wait until they figure out who
the [__] she is yeah she was a member of
Specter
apparently yeah that's a [__] up so we
did do a show about that but it was a
long time ago yeah I kind of feel like
they're getting closer to like
identifying her at least they've done
like those isotope things like on her
bones so they know where she came from
and all this other kind of stuff she was
some kind of sex operative yeah she had
to be some kind of she was they know for
sure she was like 99 sure she was a spy
like just because of all the [__] that
she had and yeah the way she died Best
Buys are women
they sleep with dudes and dudes tell
them any of everything
well that's kind of like what we're
talking about yes well I mean you know
what I mean yeah so um so yeah so they
started MK Ultra they start all of these
like little sub projects and some of the
sub-projects had to do with LSD
now it's maybe hard to imagine nowadays
but LSD was a new thing
back in the I think it was first
synthesized in what the 40s
um you know it was made in a lab it's a
synthetic drug almost 40s yeah I think
the guy uh he was a Swiss chemist
because it was Hoffman or something like
that it's a beautiful drug by the way
one of the best ones it is super fun
he's gonna be in a controlled
environment but yeah
um he was working with he wasn't trying
to make a drug like a fun drug he was
actually working with um ergot where he
was trying to what the hell was he
trying he was trying to come up with
some kind of medicine or something for
like respiratory failure or something
like that and he sort of accidentally
uh made LSD and uh at least as far as I
could determine it kind of like because
it will like soak Through Your Skin
right yeah and um so he actually like
got some on his fingers or something
like that and started like tripping
balls and so he was just kind of like
huh he's a scientist who's like this is
really interesting like I could probably
do something with tripping balls yeah
it's a whole new experience the walls
are melting it's a very visual
experience you you can drive cars you
can do all kinds of stuff you don't
really you don't become incompetent like
you would like on high doses of alcohol
or anything yeah where you're just like
falling about yeah like puking and stuff
but your your perceptions are really
altered and your way of thinking is is
altered and new ideas and night it's
nice very nice but like I said you want
to be in a damn controlled environment
for that
and you know like I said it's good to be
with some people that have done it
before experienced yeah so like if you
start to like go off the rails they can
be like hey you know they don't go
outside yeah yeah don't go roll around
in a garden don't pretend you're a
werewolf yeah Jenny wanted to do that
yeah and I talk and I'm talking from
personal experience I didn't actually
think I was a werewolf yeah it's just
you you do like role play a little bit
Yeah Yeah
yeah
that's kind of the thing yeah
yeah it's fun it's fun it is fun yeah
yeah I mean we'll have to do that again
sometime I get it yeah we got the guys
having a whole support team we got the
hook up well it's nightclubs you know
but uh but yeah so LSD was a new thing
and so
um you know immediately the scientists
saw uh the potential of this they're
like oh maybe this could be the true
serum that we're looking for their mind
control thing that we're looking for we
really need to experiment with that
because like I said it was new and
nobody really knew like what the
parameters of it were like what the
effects of it were so that's like we
really need to get on that before
another country gets onto it right
because the guy that came up with it was
uh Dutch Swiss he was Swiss the guy that
came up with it
so what they wanted to find out though
um is that like for a long time they
experimented even the CIA operatives and
stuff like that experimented themselves
uh with LSD to like see what it would do
and [__] like that but they thought that
the best way to experiment with its
effects at least in terms of what they
were trying to do
was they're like well we're gonna have
to give it to people who don't know that
they're taking it pretty much like
without their consent is what they
wanted to do
now interestingly
so when um MK Ultra started this is kind
of hilarious to think about nowadays
but they you know however much however
big the budget for Mk Ultra was nobody
really knows like I said because a lot
of the records have been lost but at
some point they commandeered an amount
of money which in today's money is about
two and a half million dollars
and it was for the purposes of buying
all the LSD and that is not an
exaggeration they were going to buy all
of the LSD that existed in the world at
that time so nobody else could get their
hands on it and so they could have this
so 2.6 million dollars quite a deal
um to buy all the LSD That Was Then in
existence uh so yeah they they
apparently did that
all the LSD in the world which is
[__] hilarious
so operation midnight climax in
particular
was run under the auspices of a dude
named Sydney Gottlieb now this guy has
many nicknames uh he's called the real
Manchurian Candidate I've also seen him
called the black sorcerer
um and various other things having to do
with poisoners and stuff because he was
actually was a chemist and he was
actually an expert in poisons and bio
weapons is was what his deal was
so basically he's like okay what we want
to do is LSD is going to be the latest
thing that we're gonna experiment on uh
and we have to
structure this somehow so that people
are going to be taking LSD but they're
not going to be like knowing about it
you know what I mean the CIA had a
[__] history of doing this they would
dose their own [__] people well we'll
get into it
you know he just thought the [__] was
funny
they wanted to see what what one of
their own members would do you know if
he didn't know
maybe like a test
it could have been just irresponsible
spook [__] having fun but
because you know yeah it was almost like
a prank like I mean it's a horrible
prank please don't do that to somebody
but I understand there's a lot of
camaraderie and special units you know
if you're like [__] if you're in an
Airborne unit or a ranger unit that we
used to [__] with each other hardcore
but they're your brothers
you just suck it up you're like yeah you
got me so maybe it was [__] like that
let's see if he take can take a heavy
[__] dose yeah yeah dose the [__] out
of him we'll keep an eye on him you know
we're getting paid anyway don't matter
you know if that thing was probably like
that yeah this was almost kind of like
like I said operation midnight climax in
particular like the way that it went
down it just to me seemed like a bunch
of stupid Frat Boys
um that were like we have all this
government money and we have hookers and
complete plausible deniability like
we're not gonna get in trouble so we can
do whatever the [__] we want to and
actually some of them did come out and
say later on it's like yeah we could
basically do whatever we wanted to it's
like that not that we're gonna get like
they're gonna get arrested or anything
like that yeah yeah cops are they were
for the CIA yeah you're just kind of
like you're you're in an Echelon above
reality right yeah so it's like they
could get away with all kind of crap
yeah
so yeah so uh experimenting with LSD
some of the other things that they were
looking into and Gottlieb was kind of
looking at this kind of stuff too they
were like it wasn't just LSD it was any
kind of like um hallucinogens or any
other kind of like Scopolamine like all
that kind of I think they were even
experimenting with that like in World
War II we did a show on scopol I mean we
did like that was a long time ago
probably not what it's cracked up to be
yeah at least we got down to the bottom
of that
some people seem to be susceptible to it
but
well like everything else like some
people are more susceptible to it right
um but yeah so they wanted to find uh
kind of drugs that would uh you know
they could put it in like uh the food
supply like in a certain building where
they wanted to like [__] with people so
people would start like freaking out in
there and they wanted to do that kind of
stuff
um and like I said they wanted ones that
were like uh that would make people
forget stuff that would like give them
Amnesia so that kind of stuff
so Sydney got leave I actually started
working for the CIA a couple of years
prior to operation midnight climax he
started in 1951 like I said he was a
chemist and he was like an expert in
poisons and bio weapons so he was
brought in
uh to run the bio Warfare program or
like you know work on the bio Warfare
program and as I mentioned because
around this time period
um there was a perception that uh the
Soviet Union and China and Korea were
maybe way ahead of us and as far as like
drug induced mind control was going like
we really need to get on top of this so
they were like we need to start this
right away so like basically three I
think it was three days after the Korean
pows like came out and like everybody
was like talking about how they were
brainwashed they basically started MK
Ultra like seriously days after like
that whole kind of [__] came out now
what you were saying previously we
probably talked about this in our MK
Ultra show but it's worth repeating
again in case you didn't see that one
what you were saying earlier about how
they would dose each other
um which I mean they would take doses
like knowingly obviously like to see how
it would affect them but yeah they would
slip it to their other uh to their
comrades or whatever like without them
knowing the most famous case of this was
poor [__] Dr Frank yeah Olson yeah
it's caused him his life now this
happened in 1953 and uh so he was a
scientist and he was also working at the
same place like he was also working in
the bio Warfare uh Department
and he gets invited like when they
started experimenting right around the
early 1950s with using LSD
um he gets invited along with several
other people to this kind of like men's
Retreat type of thing like we're having
this kind of like team building [__]
or like exercise or whatever
and at this party that they were having
he was uh dosed with LSD like in his
drink without uh him knowing
now obviously he had a really bad time
because he didn't know that he had been
dosed with LSD and all kind of crazy
[__] started happening and he didn't
really know what was happening to him
and not it wasn't the day that he was
dosed but he apparently like wasn't
really the same after that like he was
having some uh problems and whatnot well
they had him on a pretty sensitive
[__] mission I think was [__] with
his mind that too I think there were
other uh animal experimentation and [__]
and I think it was some nuke it wasn't a
bunch of nuclear weapons type testing or
bio bio weapons yeah he was in the bio
website apartment and I think something
was [__] with his Consciousness and
he killed himself that's what I think
although
uh yeah so nine or ten days after he had
been dosed with LSD
he um mysteriously jumped out a window
to his death
now interestingly
um even though it was ruled to suicide
and you know it actually did come out at
the time that he had been unwittingly
dosed with LSD and they thought maybe
that contributed however his family were
convinced that he was murdered that he
was like thrown out the window could be
also because he was gonna go tell well
later on like the his widow and like his
remaining family members they actually
sued the government and they got uh 750
000 and actually when they did they got
his body exhumed and they did a second
autopsy and that second autopsy found
that his injuries were not consistent
with a fall out the window meaning that
he had maybe been killed and first and
thrown out the window allegedly
maybe so yeah so they don't really know
so like I said the whole dosing people
like without them knowing about LSD
whether that had anything to do with his
death or not because they might have
just [__] killed him but because
maybe he knew something that they didn't
want him to know or he was gonna squeal
or some about something I think maybe
the LSD caused him to do a more
introspection about the work he was
doing with the weapon with the with bio
weapons and I think he wanted to [__]
get out of the bio weapon making
business I mean you can't blame him yeah
really I mean that'd be I don't think I
would be able to do that she either
killed himself with Guillotines or he
was gonna back out and they didn't want
him to [__] take his knowledge with
him he killed him
he might have known too much and he's
like this is look this is a one-way trip
you're working for us you can't work for
anybody else but they throw his ass out
the window
um
because I know that
if I remember correctly some of the
details the work he was working on
definitely was killing a lot of animals
wouldn't have killed a bunch of rabbits
and [__] which is a bunch of weird [__]
holy crap and then he was probably
thinking man this this [__] kills people
and maybe maybe he figured that they're
gonna use this [__] I don't want any I
don't want to you know be in that I
don't want to be part of this yeah yeah
well like I said any decent human being
would probably think the same thing I
would not be able in good conscience to
do anything like that to be a party to
anything like that you know what I mean
I just
I just couldn't I did you know I
wouldn't be able to sleep at night but
weapons are nasty they're deniable
yeah you can use them on an enemy and
say we didn't do it y'all did it because
you're dirty you do a [__] shower you
can say anything
yeah yeah it's [__] up all right it's
[__] up that people even think of that
kind of [__] yeah you know what I mean
we didn't do it you did it yeah
so yeah so
um even though so yeah so so they had
done some kind of like I wouldn't even
call those experiments because they just
seem more like cruel pranks really
um of dosing people and they would dose
like random ass people too sometimes
just like to see what would happen
but for whatever reason they thought
well this is the way that we're gonna
have to do we're gonna have to even
though it's unethical even though it's
illegal
um we're gonna have to like set up a
more uh standardized kind of experiment
where we can dose people without their
knowledge and see if we can get them to
um
tell secrets you know that they wouldn't
normally tell some other things like
that so that's what they're gonna do
so Sydney Gottlieb who is in charge of
operation midnight climax
um apparently because nobody else in the
CIA really wanted to know what he was up
to because they knew it was bad
um they pretty much just let him do what
he wanted and they were just kind of
like here's the money just don't tell us
about it just [__] go and do your
[__] and that's what you do so he brings
in this other guy whose name was George
Hunter White and the two of them were
kind of like the two main dudes that
were like running the [__] now white was
uh called a CIA consultant
now uh he wanted to do
is here's what they did Operation
midnight climax uh as its name implies
what they wanted to do they were
interested to see not only the effects
of unwitting LSD dosage but also how it
would work in combination with sex
um you know and like I said I kind of
feel like to an extent yeah it's
probably like when you think about it
it's probably like a good idea but also
I kind of feel like a couple of these
dudes were like hey we can get paid to
like sit and watch hookers or like use
hookers because they did oh yeah I'm
sure they screwed them well they did
yeah they did
um
I want to jump in some people might be
saying why do they want to know how
people would act not knowing that
there'd be a dose the main thing that
they want one of the main things I don't
know if it was particular this
particular team
but in general
what the intelligence agencies wanted to
know about [__]
um LSD was could you use it as a weapon
all right it has a very unique property
it has no overdose point
yeah which means
it's non-lethal right no matter the
dosage
so that opens up a lot of possibilities
you can use it on the battlefield
through things like crop dusting type
weapons you know you fly over with a
helicopter you just [__] dust
somebody or explosive artillery shells
that explode over the enemy and it
[__] rains down on a minute gas you
couldn't do that with say like
morphine
some of the guys would over D and OD and
die that wouldn't be a good idea so they
wanted to know what would happen if you
dosed a whole bunch of guys in the field
and they don't really know that they've
been dosed you might maybe you made it a
persistent agent
a persistent agent is like a sticky film
that covers all the trees and you walk
through it like a chemical Minefield and
it gets all over you a few hours later
you're tripping balls you didn't even
know that you got dosed they would
probably make it a persistent agent
something you spray using a crop duster
or a little pop artillery shells that
pop open and a Mist comes out then you
walk through the area and an hour later
you're tripping balls they want to know
what those soldiers would do would they
fight harder would they not fight at all
would they surrender would they kill
each other they probably just lay down
in the grass and go ooh yeah
could you walk up on them and just get
them to surrender once they're like that
could you play a bunch of music while
they're tripping balls and just walk in
there and be friendly to them and then
just take them because they'd be like
cool man yeah yeah you know so they want
to know that's what they wanted to know
now the sex thing they're talking about
sex agents right there could you get
some is it easy to get dirt on somebody
if they're you know under the influence
of [__] LSD that's that's probably
what they're talking about
Camp guy said I always wanted to be high
when having sex yes
what's stopping you well yeah I mean you
you can there's nothing stopping yeah
Sir John Doe the great said did you guys
like the 1984 V miniseries kind of off
topic sorry that's okay we're all about
off topic here
um I remember liking it but I haven't
seen it in a very very long time I
probably I might have not seen it since
1984 to be honest with you I mean I
think I saw it when it came out but I
don't really remember what about it John
Gore said what was the chemical in
George mirror's The Crazies called
Trixie yeah it was something like that I
think it was called Trixie I haven't
seen the crazies in a really long time I
actually wanted to do I know there was a
remake I haven't seen the Remake but
I've seen the original a couple times
and I actually wanted to do like a
review on it but I just haven't got
around to it yet
I just haven't got around to it
so yeah so so what they were gonna do so
this is what they did your tax dollars
at work I'm gonna say
so the CIA they had these safe houses
they had a couple of them there was one
in San Francisco I think there was two
of them in San Francisco and then there
was one somewhere else in California and
then there was one in uh New York City
might have been in Greenwich Village I
can't actually remember
what they did was they took these safe
houses and they fitted them out like
Swanky looking apartments or like
essentially they set them up as brothels
is what they did
so they would go in there and they said
it was kind of hilarious like um George
Hunter white like he goes in there like
decorate the [__] and he decorate it
just like you would imagine like a
brothel would look like he's got like
you know big red velvet curtains and
it's like he hangs up like you know
erotic art on the walls like he's got
some toulouse-lautrec Prince up there
like to class up the joint like all
because you know what I mean like so
he's got like all the all the
pornographic art on the walls and
everything and the red curtains and the
red wallpaper and all that and all that
kind of [__]
so they set up essentially brothels is
what they were now the brothels also
they had it fixed up they had this kid
I wasn't a kid he was a college student
like an engineering student from
Berkeley and he has this kid come in and
rig up
um monitoring equipment in all of the
rooms including
um like a two-way mirror so people could
be sitting on the other side of the
mirror and they could watch everything
that was going on in the bedrooms so
there was that
so then they would go and they would
hire local sex workers
and they basically said
um we just want you to basically just
like lure random dudes off the street
and bring them in here
dose them without like give them a drink
that has LSD in it like without them
knowing
have sex with them
and then like have them hang out for a
little while we want to see if we can
get them to like say [__] that they
wouldn't normally say at least 45
minutes then yeah good now the sex
workers they I think they did get paid a
little bit of cash but I think most of
the perks that they got was they got
like essentially like a get out of jail
free card they're like oh if you get
arrested just like call this number and
we'll get you out of the clink or
whatever so they knew that did they know
it was a CIA
you know what I don't know and it's like
and I don't really know what happened to
any of those women afterward either like
they were all just local
women that you know just worked around
the streets like I said there were there
was more than one they had like I think
there were two in San Francisco there
was one somewhere else in California and
there was one in New York City also but
they all had the kind of the same setup
and they would just kind of like hire
the local girls and they would just
bring in random and it didn't matter
like it didn't matter
um and actually they even said like in
some of the papers that survived they
were just like they wanted a broad
sampling of humanity I guess so it
didn't matter if the people were
Americans or if they were foreign or if
they were whoever it's just like whoever
they could get to like come in there
um that's who they wanted so they would
get them to come in there
like I said dose them with the [__] and
then
after they had sex then they would kind
of like
pretend like they wanted to sort of like
spend more time with them or like talk
to them
because one thing that they found out
over the course of these experiments so
I guess this was something even though I
was watching um Bailey sarian she did a
dark history episode on this on you know
MK Ultra in particular it's really funny
like if you haven't seen it's like an
hour long she's I love her and she's
like cute as a button so she did a thing
about this and she was talking about
she's like oh well one thing they
discovered was that you know after dudes
have had sex they're like a lot more
vulnerable and if you like start talking
to them like they'll say anything she's
like I could have told those
[__] that for free it's like I
don't really know it you know what I
mean it's like I don't know why they
needed a [__] experiment in like
Joseph with LSD because I don't I feel
like the LSD didn't really factor into
um any of the information that they were
trying to get because yeah they did
discover that the dudes would like spill
their guts
afterward but it was usually just
because the women were talking to them
and seemed like they wanted to hang out
with them I don't even know if it was
the LSD doing probably not no I don't
kind of feel like no LSD doesn't make
you give up Secrets no that's what I
mean if you trip balls you see stuff but
you're you're still on guard you're not
helpless yeah you see this is another
thing
I kind of touched on it earlier
just
Intel operatives
ties if that's who want to call them
spooks
undercover cops
[__] uh Elite [__] Commandos
all have drug resistance they'll give
them drug resistance
um one of them is sodium penthol
that was one that was one of the reasons
why sodium pentathol wasn't [__]
effective is because guys who who were
in the Intel business would take it to
build a resistance to it
so they would
drugs like that are only good on a first
timer somebody who doesn't really know
what's going on they're vulnerable to it
if you gave it to a guy who's been under
sodium pentatholic for a long time small
doses of he goes oh this is [__]
sodium Pepto you know what they're doing
you know what I mean and then you start
playing games with them you you can
build up a resistance to drugs
well yeah and I and I feel like anyone
that's in that line of work it would be
move you to yeah to develop a resistance
just in case the [__] gets used on You
by in front of me and um
a person can take these drugs and not
become addicted if you have a strong
personality other personalities can't do
it they have an addictive personalities
they're very easy to get addicted your
drug your drug addicts all have
addictive personalities now there's some
of them that are [__] some of them I
wouldn't even try like that hard to come
back
you don't want to [__] around with
heroine heroin is so good you want to
keep going back to it
uh cocaine easy to fight if you just
there's a certain technique you use you
can snort cocaine the next day you'll
want some more just get [__] blind
drunk you'll forget all about [__]
cocaine and then the next day you wake
up you just you don't even freaking
remember you don't want alcohol
yeah
you just you just can't get caught up in
a habit
well a lot of these guys the James Bond
[__] do that kind of [__]
because uh and the same thing with
[__]
uh narcotics agents they do drugs they
have to do drugs that's part of their
[__] job their undercover narcotics
agents so they're hanging around with
drug dealers in the drug trade taking
drugs
yeah I mean you'd kind of have to yeah
yeah because we talked about that when
we were talking about that when we did
the movie review of training day yeah
because that was I was like well yeah
like if you're an undercover narcotics
agent yeah you're gonna take some drugs
yeah whether you want to or not it's
going to be your job because
that's going to be your proof that
you're not a cop right because they see
you [__] doing those drugs no dude's
a cop
and they're under the erroneous
assumption that a cop won't do any drugs
I'm like where have you been my mind was
blown
in 101st Airborne Division when I found
out CID which that's the military
version of the FBI used sex operatives
who female Army sex operatives they used
them as agents
there was a guy I was in Korea with he
was a stinger Gunner
later on in the 101st I saw him
[__] saw him and I was riding a
motorcycle and I saw him standing in a
doorway of a cute little house standing
next to a [__] hippie chick and he
was looking like a hippie too
and I was like I was like hey man I
haven't seen you since Korea and I came
in [__] hung out with him
dude offered me a joint it says Nah I
don't smoke that and I noticed his
girlfriend looked happy that I said no
and then I just ended up leaving later
on
I saw that dude about five months later
he wasn't living there anymore it was
somewhere else I said what happened to
your girlfriend she goes oh that wasn't
my girlfriend he said like what are you
talking about dude she was a CID agent
it's like what it's like yeah they had
me under investigation they thought I
was part of some kind of weed selling
ring I just knew some dudes I wasn't but
he got kicked out
hmm that girl was CID and she went in
there and lived with him for [__] 18
months
[__] him and being his girlfriend for
18 months trying to figure out can you
imagine that was her [__] job and I
was my mind was blown that they got
basically hoes working
for them in CID that that's that's what
a female agent does she [__] dudes who
they want to arrest
I don't know what kind of Psych that is
thankless [__] job I don't know what
kind of [__] psycho chick that they
[__] get for that but she was a
[__] CID agent
I mean maybe like I said just like
everything else and just like the dudes
in this particular case thought it's
like well I don't know if all of them
thought this but I'm sure some of them
thought oh we're doing it for like a
higher purpose yeah International
security reasons like this is a criminal
and I'm catching the criminal exactly
you know it sucks that I have to [__]
him but you know yeah but she's got to
be a psycho she lived that dude [__]
18 months pretending to be his
girlfriend I can't imagine I'm living
doing that and it turned out he wasn't
who they were looking for yeah but she
still she went up there and testified
against him and they they didn't do
anything to him just they just kicked
him out he wasn't the one they were
looking for
I just can't I didn't I just can't
imagine but I read the body when I said
no to the [__] drugs I saw her mood
lighting
I was like that's weird
because you think she'd been mad yeah
she was supposed to be a civilian what
my weed's not good yeah yeah cause she
was a civilian I didn't know she was
military right yeah and she was like oh
he's he's one of us he's the good guy
he's one of the good guys
ain't that some [__] that is some [__]
yeah
like I said man I would I could never
respect a woman that did that
well I mean it's their job but it's not
why would you want that job [__] that
would you would they would you take a a
job where they send you into absolutely
not [__] drug Den to [__] drug
dealers for [__] 18 months and
pretend to be their boyfriends and then
testify against them absolutely [__] man
well it's like not only that would never
go out with a girl like that well that I
mean one that's like super unpleasant
anyway like having to Live 24 7 like as
a drug dealer with a bunch of drug
dealers and like pretend to be someone
you're not yeah and then after that like
you'd have to testify against them and
like you might get your ass [__]
killed yeah you know what I mean and you
might have liked the guy he might have
been a good guy no thanks yeah that's
another thing what if the guy was a good
guy but what if you had feelings for him
and you still did that yeah
you got to be some kind of psycho yeah I
can't imagine the kind of person that
would want to do that yeah
but no once I saw that I was like I
don't trust anybody I don't trust any
government [__]
dirty [__] I mean that's [__]
up
so uh so yeah so they set up all these
brothels right and they just start
pulling random ass dudes they didn't
have like I said they didn't have any
um parameters about what kind of people
they want to pull to just anybody
anybody that could get pulled in they
were just like interested to get
somebody get some Intel you want me to
freshen that up yeah that'd be good
get some Intel on whoever the [__] just
wandered into this brothel or whatever
now here's some [__] up [__]
so
um so the guy like uh George Hunter
white they actually have one of his
letters that he wrote I believe he wrote
it to Sydney Gottlieb
and this is this letter like something
he said in there
was the reason that I suspect that he
was just doing that I don't think he
gave a [__] about
mind control or helping National
Security or anything like that I
honestly I think he was just having a
good time and getting his rocks off you
know what I mean basically because he
wrote a letter to Sydney I think it was
just Sydney Gottlieb and he basically
said he was just having fun like I said
and he said and this is a quote from his
letter where else could a red-blooded
American Boy lie kill and cheat steal
deceive rape and pillage with the
sanction and blessing of the all highest
I mean he was just having a [__]
blast
I will also note that George Hunter
White
who I guess was kind of like the second
in command he was like a CIA consultant
um it's pretty widely uh accepted that
whenever he was in town because he was
from New York City he was as far as I
know he was married and had kids and all
that uh and all that but whenever he was
in San Francisco
he would specifically
get um services from this from the sex
workers that they were employing to
bring the people in for their
quote-unquote experiment and uh very
proudly he said that they never charged
him so they were giving him [__] for
free
uh so good for him I guess
but yeah
now another thing that this [__]
did so like I said remember I said that
they installed
um you know the two-way mirrors like
behind all the things so they could
watch so they would basically just sit
there and watch
the the hookers like have sex with the
Johns you know and give them drugs and
just like see what happened
so
white in particular and I don't know if
they did this in all the rooms or not
they call okay so the they called the
place around in San Francisco they
called it the pad
and some even some of the other CIA
operatives like at the time said oh my
God it was like a big [__] frat party
over there it's like everybody they had
a mini fridge in there like Behind the
Walls like where the windows were and
they had like big pictures of martinis
in there so it's like basically they
would just they're on the clock you guys
they're like on the job just like I said
your tax dollars at work they're but
sitting there Behind the Walls drinking
martinis
and I saw a thing that said two that
said like sometimes it was like eight
Martini lunches and [__] like I was like
eight martinis Jesus Christ like how are
they still standing up but yeah so they
so they would just like sit there and
drink martinis and watch the prostitutes
[__] the dudes
engine and all in the name of like
[__] science or whatever the [__]
they were calling it also and this is
the best part
so not only were they sitting there with
big pictures of ice cold martinis
watching live-action porn
but George White
under the excuse that he's like well I
don't want to miss a minute of the
action
thank you so he commandeered and they
and they have the one of the papers that
survived is his um uh you know the the
thing that he uh submitted like for the
money for this
he got a portable toilet installed
behind the two-way glass so that he
could basically sit there on the can
drink in the martini out of his mini
fridge and watching The Prostitute
[__] the dude like I said just and
get paid for it why does it need to be
sitting on a can
well I mean he had the can there in case
he had to in case he had to go in case
he had to go yeah I mean maybe it's like
idiocracy where he was just like sitting
there all the time just in case
I was thinking that's kind of where my
mind went to yeah
well you never know he's drinking all
these martinis and they probably just
like go through Ugo right through you
yeah so it's like so he's just sitting
so basically I'm like so they're paying
or actually the American taxpayer is
paying for these dudes they have for
these Joey 50s era [__] yeah to
watch it there and watch hookers on
their portable toilets and drink
martinis out of their mini fridges yeah
oh and also like I said white I'm not
sure about the other CIA operatives but
but I'm sure they did this too but white
for sure
um did indulge in the sex workers as
well and I don't think you were here but
he whenever he came to San Francisco
because he didn't live in San Francisco
he lived in New York City and he was
married too but every time he would come
to San Francisco he'd be like hey I want
this girl and that girl and it's like
and they said oh they never charged him
yeah like he got him for free yeah
so again I kind of feel like this whole
experiment I don't think he really gave
a [__] about like what they found out
about it I don't really I think he was
just like getting off on likewise man
it's a great job well yeah he's like
this is the best job ever I'm just like
sitting here [__] drinking martinis
and watching live action porn I think
they thought they might learn something
though
but I don't think they did well that's
what I was going to say did they learn
anything they learned that it didn't
work
which I guess that's but I imagine you
try to try to stretch that out as long
as you can let's just keep trying bro do
you know how long operation midnight
climax went on I didn't even realize
nine years oh yeah yeah they're actually
maybe longer it might have gone on for
like 10 years they're riding the gravy
train right yeah well I mean if that was
your job yeah you could like you're
gonna be like yeah we're we're totally
getting like all kinds of really good
information we need to like continue
these experiments yeah we're getting
good results they're just in their
[__] partying man they got a [__]
fridge full of martinis they had a
pitcher of martinis in there imagine
James Bond doing this [__]
ridiculous and it's like I'm watching
this going oh my God dudes are the
literal worst it's like what the [__]
man somebody fell for it it's grift yeah
big time well did they dose every single
guy
yeah it wasn't always LSD they used some
other substances too but it was mostly
LSD so what happened to the repeat
customers did would they have repeat
customers see I don't know like I said
there's because so much of the of the
paperwork has been destroyed and like I
said they didn't I don't even know if
their goal was really to get any
actionable intelligence out of any of
this crap because it really doesn't seem
like they got any
useful information and the only thing
they learned like I said was that you
know yeah guys would start spilling [__]
after sex like if the woman like stayed
there like was actually engaged to like
talk to them and I was like I don't even
know if that was so much the LSD that
was doing that you know what I mean it
might because I think they might have
been proud of doing it anyway they
probably would have done that anyway so
give him a drink and they probably would
have done it even better right that's
what I mean so I don't really think the
administering of LSD like you know
without their knowledge yeah
um was really
it didn't really bring the results that
they wanted now it did have some like
bad um consequences because a couple of
people
that were um either
that were either certainly or allegedly
dosed during these experiments like
without their knowledge one dude in
particular I can't remember what his
name was but um he was dosed and then he
started like I think he was dosed either
at the brothel or at a party I can't
really remember but he was like thinking
that everybody he didn't know he'd been
dosed so he thought everybody hated him
all of a sudden and then he decided that
he was gonna show everybody and he was
gonna go hold up a store okay yeah like
like you do he's gonna punish him and so
yeah so he goes to a store and like
[__] waves a gun at the deal he
didn't hurt anybody thankfully but um
after they found out what had happened
they kind of like he did get some time
but they went kind of easy on him
because after they figured out what was
going on who figured out what was going
on
um well I think like the judge it like
figured out was going because he's like
look man it's like I think somebody like
slipped me some [__] and I didn't know
what was going on like all that other
kind of stuff so they kind of like went
kind of behind him I didn't come in and
save his ass no no no obviously not so
so [__] like that happened because that
was another thing that they were trying
to do with these dudes that they'd bring
into the brothels is that not only were
they trying to see if they would like
spill their guts or like say like secret
[__] but they also wanted to see if they
could like plant suggestions in their
minds
um specifically to do like illegal [__]
and then see if they would do it right
um because I guess they wanted to find
something right they wanted to see if
they could get somebody to like
assassinate somebody or like do a
robbery or some [__] like that like that
they wouldn't normally do yeah they're
kind of [__]
they're kind of they're kind of hoping
that LSD has capabilities that it
doesn't
that maybe you can just [__] talk
somebody to killing somebody else on the
influence of that [__] no
that's how that's nice rare cases you
could get that to work but I kind of
feel like in most cases that would not
work you'd have to have somebody that
already had motive yeah like I yeah I
kind of feel like it would be somebody
that already kind of had proclivities in
that direction yeah like somebody that
wouldn't do that normally I don't think
they would do it if they were on LSD you
would think that these CIA guys taking
that drug on their own themselves
and once they got a feel for it would
realize that that drug won't do that
it's not that mind-altering it's more
like altering your perception the way
you see things yeah it's not like
changing your whole it doesn't change
your personality personality or your
whole and like I said it's weird because
the weird thing it's and it's really
hard to explain to somebody that hasn't
done it but it's like it Alters your
perceptions but you're aware that your
perceptions are altered yeah it's not
like you're so [__] up right that you
don't know what you're doing or so
because you know it's like sometimes if
you've been like really blackout drunk
you might like do or say like [__] that
you don't even like know which and you
don't even remember the next day yeah
that doesn't do that LSD doesn't do that
um it's like you're very very aware it's
almost kind of like I don't know it's
true Crystal Clear it's it's almost like
and this isn't exactly right but this is
the only way that I can explain it it's
almost like you're like
you're of two minds at the same but not
like because you kind of know that it's
like oh I'm seeing all this crazy [__]
but you know that it's not real yeah you
know and you're still very like Lucid
about it yeah exactly it's kind of like
you have um two points of view at the
same time that yeah that's maybe more
like a better way of putting it you're
tripping balls but you know you're
tripping balls right and there's a part
of you that's totally straight
and you know what I mean and rational
there's another party that's tripping
balls and you're kind of laughing at the
part the trip evolved right yeah that's
exactly what it's like it's a it's a
it's a pleasant experience at least it
always has been for me I never had a bad
trip I thought it was always good
yeah because like you know during that
time like when she's got to set the
stage for it yeah and it's it's like
when he was like teasing me about like
me like rolling around in the grass and
thinking I was a werewolf it's like I
didn't actually think I was a werewolf
yeah but it's like a fantasy I liked the
idea that I was a werewolf but I knew I
wasn't really a werewolf she walked
around the house [__] touching the
walls
they were all painted blue you know what
I mean wow this is great and looking at
they felt neat looking at the screen
and I pull up you know I'm looking at
the [__] laptop [__] singing along
to David Bowie [__] 70s David Bowie
and she's walking her this is great so
yeah yeah this is great you know she
kept and then I had to keep babysitting
her because it was her first time
let's go outside you know don't go
outside no no no stay right here we'll
be okay yeah stay stay in the house
then the [__] UPS man showed up we're
like whoa whoa hold on oh my God I still
laugh when I got it outside for this
[__] hold on man yeah we had all I told
UPS Maps was okay that's not here for
this okay look man I'm tripping balls
and he started laughing because what do
I gotta do it's okay let me sign right
here and you were like it's very very
slowly I was like all right thank you
man you have a good one hit I said don't
tell on me you're good well prior to
that like the UPS guy rang the doorbell
and we both like flipped out yeah yeah
because we didn't know who it was it was
like Tuesday afternoon I told him not to
tell on me
who was that we're in trouble wanted me
to sign for the package yeah and then
it's like I still laugh when I think
about Tom like signing like really
slowly
so [__] funny it was just like one of
the funniest things that ever happened
it's just happened in an upscale
neighborhood
we probably made that dude's day I kind
of feel like he's probably like oh my
god dude that was a normal dude and the
two of them are religious like the same
EPS man all the time I'd see him like
what's up
yeah it was just that was there Florida
man
but yeah he's probably like yeah but
it's probably not even the weirdest
thing he saw that day probably no
uh Sir John Doe the great said don't
watch the 79 Salem's Lot tripping LMAO
yeah that sounds like you had a problem
I love that movie
um we didn't watch any movies while we
were tripping we were mostly just like
listening to the music and watch music
videos and watching videos and stuff
but um
um so now I was listening to uh David
Bowie and David Bowie videos
Billy Idol Billy Idol videos yeah
you thought David Bowie was talking to
you well like he was talking to you you
didn't literally think not literally
yeah but it was uh it's a god-awful
hair yeah what's the name of that
[__]
is there life on Mars yeah yeah that's
my arm that's when I was remembering
yeah yeah yeah we listen to a lot of
them yeah
Sailors fighting on the Dance Floor
oh man look at those cavemen go I'm
[__] tripping balls and Jen's coming
in and this is what are you doing is I'm
talking to David Bowie yeah okay yeah
well and the thing about it too was that
I was trying to talk to our friend Jen
because she had never done it and she
asked me to tell her yeah she's on the
phone like what it was doing and I
actually initially tried to message her
on my laptop and that was not working
out because my laptop was like was going
woo like that and like I was like I was
like oh my fingers are really long I
can't type so so I had to call her and
talk to her on the phone but um
later on because you know if you haven't
done it it lasts like a really long time
yeah Jen smokes a [__] ton of weed so
she wanted to know what LSD was like
yeah yeah yeah but and I don't like weed
nah I know some people really like it
and I'm not hating I'm just like I I
don't um I I never had like a good
experience with weed it's crappy it
never it always made me feel like
shittier than yeah it gave me like more
anxiety well that's why I liked LSD
because LSD when I took that I was like
oh I understand what everybody's talking
about like oh like I understand the
hippies now because they're all just
kind of like we're all one man and it's
like will you feel like that like you
and you feel like everything's gonna be
okay yeah which I I was like that's
awesome I kind of wish I like I felt
like that all the time yeah it's all
spiritual and visual and [__] right it's
real clean feeling you don't yeah you
don't feel intoxicated yeah you feel
like straight
like alcohol makes you feel a lot more
intoxicated than than LSD does
yeah uh and I I never liked weed we'd
always kind of had a kind of a crappy
ghetto feel to it it felt really it
always felt real cheap
kind of dirty I never I just never liked
that I always felt super paranoid on a
week yeah yeah it's just it's just not
it's just not that good I you know
either like different kinds I've tried
it's like everybody's like well you
haven't had this kind and it's like I'm
like nope that did it too I like alcohol
LSD and Coke
but I the thing is Coke's too expensive
you can't
I've never paid for it I've only been
giving it to me people give it to me
I'll do that yeah we had somebody give
us some yeah a couple years ago if you
start paying for it the next thing you
know you because you're you're [__]
hooked on this [__] so you never pay for
that that's always something somebody
gives you it apart and I'm not I'm not a
big fan
um because I already have like anxiety
and [__] like that and my brain goes a
mile a minute so I definitely don't need
anything that like amps me up you know
what I mean I absolutely do not need it
if you're real drunk somebody gives you
Coke you pump a few lines and all of a
sudden you're sober you can drink more
well that might help that that's that
was one of the main things I liked about
it but I'm just saying your mouth would
run [__] a million miles a minute man
you talk big [__] when you're on coke
you just become an [__] well like I
said so now you wait to see me I'm Coke
that's what I mean see you don't need
that you don't need it you don't need
that you're already like naturally
you're already naturally uncooked like
all the time
so it's like you don't you don't need
that Amplified yeah but like I said I
think that that's why I liked LSD so
much because it just like [__] it
chilled me out I was like yeah man
everything's okay everything uh when I
was saying and I had never felt like
that before when I was in Egypt we were
smoking
um opium opium is real nice
uh it's habit forming if you smoke it
too long but if you just smoke it once
and you can walk away from it it doesn't
have a pull on you it's like it's not
like you think about it afterwards the
Opium was real nice there's a great
smoke it's like real heavy oily kind of
grape flavored
tobacco smoke like a pipe smoke
and it just slows you down you get real
real [__] relaxed uh I like that one
but that's not something you could do on
a regular basis you know what I mean
yeah I mean you know
I don't know if I beat well I'd probably
be down to try that but yeah that one's
not very addictive people you know they
used had opium dens yeah yeah but you'd
have to smoke that a lot to get hooked
on it right you know
um like but you know and you'd also
probably have to have an addictive
personality but that's physically
addictive but it's nowhere near like
heroin you know it's
it's tenth of that easily and I've never
really had any urge to try heroin
you know
I mean I like a lot of musicians that
were on heroin and it's like some of the
way they talk about it I'm like yeah it
sounds kind of cool but nah I mean to be
honest it just sounds like it makes them
like kind of chill out and sleep all the
time and I'm like that sounds really
boring I don't know like maybe it's
maybe it feels really good I don't
really know but it's just like doesn't
really sound all that interesting to me
like I said LS like hallucinogens always
sounded interesting because you know of
the whole like opening up your
perception and like you know amping up
your creativity and [__] like that like
I'm down for that kind of stuff but like
other kind of [__] that just like numbs
your emotions or does any of that kind
of crap that doesn't interest me I don't
really like anything I can understand
why some people would want to do that
but that's not really my thing I would
just if I'm gonna do drugs I would
rather do something that like
you know makes everything looks look
really cool or like chills me out or
something like that because you know
like I said I need to be chilled out
that's why I'm not and I've done coke
before but it's not that's also not for
me I don't need anything that like
amphetamines or anything that's gonna
like make me even more [__] anxious
and Spazzy than I already am
because that's everyone's just gonna
have a bad time
so you know I mean now interestingly so
here's the thing so this project went on
that they know of from 1953 until it was
kind of like officially shut down in
1964. so it was like 11 years and it
might have gone on longer than that
because I think the one in New York City
went on slightly longer
what's interesting about this is that
ostensibly MK Ultra as a whole
they were kind of trying to use drugs
and other methods what
Victor Garcia said I smoked weed when I
was 13 and it made me gay everything
made everything made you gay Victor well
yeah that's seeing something funny every
time who else what else made Victor gay
didn't he didn't he say seeing uh seeing
uh [__] um the back the arch back
arch of [__] oh right right what was
his name Tom Hardy yeah Tom Hardy's back
Arts
made him gay uh [__] Doctor Who made
him gay
[__] everything made you gay Victor
well it was probably don't blame your
gayness on these governments just own it
bro
that was an amazing butt angle though I
was impressed I was as well as a
straight man I was impressed I was like
I'm sitting there going holy [__] I
respect your game Tom Hardy
yeah that was that was pre-steroid cycle
[__] uh uh pretty boy Tom Hardy
trying to [__] get those jobs get
those Hollywood jobs with the back arch
he knew Hollywood well
if I arch my back like this and touch
the mirror I'll get some [__] to work
it worked it worked
that was his old MySpace photos
Zach says my mama's womb made me gay
probably closer to the truth
mango said Victor is gay LOL
no yeah
um but but yeah
so um so okay so what I was saying was
the ironic thing is that ostensibly
the goal of MK Ultra and operation
midnight climax any of the ones that had
to do with LSD
they were supposedly trying to come up
with mind control [__] to use against
America's enemies
um you know and various other things in
terms of National Security
however it seems that really the only
thing it accomplished was perhaps
indirectly or directly maybe kick
starting the counterculture because what
they ended up doing with all these MK
Ultra experiments because you have to
think LSD a Swiss dude invented in a lab
it wasn't like on the streets it wasn't
nothing like that so then like the CIA
buys all of the LSD and starts giving it
to random college students and other
dudes in San Francisco and [__] like
that and they loved the [__] yeah and so
they like told their friends about it
and they're like they're all like
signing up for Mk Ultra take give me
some of that please that's like some
pretty awesome [__] and then like it
ended up causing like I said the whole
like almost the very thing that they
were trying to prevent I feel like
Scrappers in the comments section I have
not seen him okay
I'm gonna tell you all the story
grandpas can back this up he's a [__]
ex he's a cop I grew up with
we went to high school together he knows
all my friends and [__] well he went
to high school for a couple years ago
and I also went did a couple years in
Brazil too for high school
me and my boy he knows who I'm talking
about he used to [__] score some some
of the best [__] window pain of
[__] 1980 [__] six all right 87
run that time
where we got that
was a university in Michigan I'm not
going to name which one that's where it
came from and it came from the [__]
chemistry Labs well yeah they make it
the biochemistry Labs the students make
the [__] yeah because the laboratory is
right there
and um
a lot of it they give away for free
it's like here try this batch out yeah
because it's amazing recipes it's made
out of real common [__]
you just need the equipment to do it
there's no difference between making
like one Tab and a thousand tabs it's
cost the same
and not very much
so for a few hundred bucks you could get
a whole [__] City High
and it doesn't have a long shelf life
so I think they sell some of it to
people certain targeted clients but then
they have all this extra [__] they just
give it away
now
I think we paid for it usually but we
could get free stuff too and it was
coming from universities
and it all was like album covered be
like album [__] dark Pink Floyd Dark
Side of the Moon album cover was one and
then like [__] umaguma with the green
teeth album cover
and this [__] was [__] wild it was
[__] good it was better than the [__]
we got here that's how good that [__]
was
you could take two hits you'd be [__]
flying you couldn't take four
I could take four hits of the other
stuff that we had the other day but
still one's enough and it was clean
clean stuff you'd wake up the next
morning after a good sleep you'd be all
right you'd be like oh we'll see the
[__] we did like the next day I felt
yeah you feel like [__] terrible Yeah
clean stuff you feel worse it was worth
it though it wasn't like a hangover it
was different just worn out man I was
worn out every one of your neurons is
firing [__] nukes yeah extremely
[__] and I was sore yeah my face was
sore from smiling the whole time yeah
because I was having a good time but
yeah it's like it's it's weird but yeah
my [__] face was sore from smiling
and I just yeah I felt exhausted because
it like it lights up like it feels like
it lights up your whole entire brain so
you're like your brain is just coming up
with all this crazy [__] and then like
the next day you're just like [__]
tired out Victor says he's not gay as a
top
[Laughter]
I mean [__] I'll [__] introduce
you my boy [__] he's a power top bro
BDSM
like you've been hit by a [__] four
or five Rob Halfords all at once he's
top of [__] but he's gay
gay
you know being top doesn't mean you're
straight
I'm pretty sure he's choking time yeah
Zach says if Tom wants a great high he
should try the elixir of Destiny a mix
of Dr Pepper cough medicine and Windex
[__] Windex are you trying to be the
elevator killer that was the kind of
[__] that made your brain die last and
Man with Two Brains did you guys see
that movie but tell me you saw that
movie we did a review of it a long time
ago Steve Martin was in it
but yeah so so so that's the thing I
kind of feel like the CIA
of probably unwittingly because I feel
like they went into this they didn't
know what the [__] they were doing you
know what I mean they just thought oh
here's this neat new drug and maybe we
can use it to mind control people so
let's just like give it to people but
like I said the people that they gave it
to which was mostly like college
students and like young people and stuff
like that ended up liking it and so it
kind of got around by word of mouth and
then suddenly it's like oh man let's all
[__] trip balls and then like I said
I kind of feel like it sort of
kick-started the whole yeah I mean it
might have happened anyway but like not
exactly in the same way you know well
they put them they put the word out on
the street and then there was a demand
right we want more of that we want more
of that because that's like super fun
yeah Timothy Leary getting involved in
it oh this is great [__] well Ken keezy
the guy that wrote One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest I mean he said he
attributed
like his involvement in the whole
counterculture to that like because he
was in he actually volunteered because
some of the people did volunteer it
wasn't all
um slipping its people without their
knowledge I mean as [__] up as that is
they did have some like other sub things
of like MK Ultra that people actually
like volunteered for although like most
scientific experiments I think they
didn't tell them exactly like what the
what the um goal of the experiment was
because that would take the data but um
but they knew that it had something to
do with like taking LSD or experimenting
so a lot of people were like ooh sign me
up for that let me make a caveat
like I said before uh to make this stuff
is cheap you just need the equipment and
the knowledge
it doesn't cost really anymore to make
it strong or weak okay about the same
price
the LSD of this era
was a lot stronger than the LSD of my
area or era or the era of today
one dose back then was probably like
four or five six doses of today
so there were stories of [__] [__]
going weird with people taking LSD back
in the 60s yeah and it was because they
were way overdosed there's no overdose
point to where it'll kill you it's just
that
you can take a lot of if you too much of
that [__] you you can lose touch with
reality right uh you you can't really
control it so
a modern hit
is a lot more manageable than
maybe like a random hit from back in the
60s where you weren't sure they weren't
uniform
one batch a hit was you could do it
another badge it hit was like six of the
other hits
and it was just one
so you weren't sure the strength
so there was a lot of problems but now
you know it's made pretty mild
because you know it didn't take much
doesn't take much you kind of want it to
be mild
that way you can manage it and if you
want more you can take a little bit more
if it's too strong you might get more
than you want yeah it's better to kind
of just start out with a small there's
and then like I said if you want like
more you can just take more just put
another tab in there and like [__]
you know what I mean yes like if it's
not
was unreliable you weren't sure how
strong it was and some of that [__] was
[__] super strong
yeah so you can see how some people
actually did [__] just completely
freak out because like you said if you
have enough like you do like lose touch
with you oh we're getting all kinds of
money is that New Zealand Dollars it is
yes thank you all the way down to New
Zealand who is that thank you Bryce
right it's okay apparently L Ron Hubbard
used LSD to research aliens oh sure yeah
he's getting that'll help getting in
contact with alien Souls take some
you'll understand I mean that explains a
lot about like how he how he [__]
yeah hell yeah he says love the show as
always thank you thank you thank you we
are having a good time on this yeah so
some other people
that um allegedly or I'm not even sure
if it's allegedly I'm pretty sure they
know that um some people that actually
did volunteer for these LSD experiments
and um later ended up uh uh not having
so good time Charles Manson one of them
uh Whitey Bulger the very famous uh
mobster and uh the Unabomber Ted
Kaczynski and I think we talked about
that when we did the Ted Kaczynski show
that he I don't remember if he actually
volunteered or if he was dosed
against his will
because I kind of feel like they did a
lot of experience even though like
obviously the the CIA experiments that
are the most notorious are the ones that
you know where they were dosing people
against their will because that's [__]
up like don't do that to people but they
did do a lot of even MK Ultra
experiments where they dose people like
and they knew that they were getting
dosed you know what I mean but some of
those people
like I said
um it's the results didn't turn out so
good I'm not saying that Charles Manson
would have been a totally normal person
if he hadn't like [__] been in these
experiments if indeed he was but because
like I said I kind of feel like
I don't know I don't know if this is
true or not and it might just be like
talking out my ass or something but I
feel like drugs unless you're given like
a [__] ton of so many drugs that like
you don't even know what the [__] way is
up anymore I kind of feel like they're
not gonna make you do anything
that you wouldn't normally do you know
what I mean like with with some caveats
like with that because I know that like
people get super super drunk and they'll
do [__] that they probably wouldn't do
while they were sober because it gets
rid of all your inhibitions but I'm just
saying that even when you're super drunk
the [__] that you're doing or saying is
probably [__] that you would do or say
if you were sober if you thought that
there wouldn't be any consequences you
know what I'm saying like I didn't I
don't know I don't think you could get
somebody to kill somebody
on a drug unless they already kind of
wanted to do that and I could be totally
wrong about that and I guess it would
depend on the dosage well you could say
you might be able to come in and say
well what about uh
Charles Manson
and his [__] what was the name of his
[__] uh cult uh the spooky kids
that's the Maryland man the family the
family they did some [__] and they were
taking a lot of LSD right but they might
have just been [__] up and they were
[__] up anyway guaranteed uh that's
the point that I was making is they
probably had problems anyway and I don't
think it was just the LSD I don't think
it was a cult environment right I don't
think you could take like a normal
person and give them LSD and be like go
assassinate a president I don't think
they're gonna do that you could have
taken the LSD away from the Manson
family and they still would have killed
Cherry that's what I'm saying it
wouldn't have mattered I think they were
just [__] up anyway weed would have
been enough they were just like getting
high but uh Charles Manson's [__]
diatribe and his [__]
fantasies so I can got a hold of naive
girls basically
yeah
and who needed a father figure yeah it
was very shame that it was a shame they
were actually real pretty girls
from decent families
and uh Charlie just [__] him up told
him a bunch of [__] you know I think
he may be halfway believed what he was
talking about and then when I killed
somebody over it cost not only did
Sharon Tate and her friends their lives
it cost those girls Squeaky from and all
the other it cost them their lives too
because they spent the rest of their
lives in prison or Charlie's [__]
stupid [__] they're just young young
naive girls
yeah and basically a sex cult basically
that's the thing girls don't don't
listen to any dudes any [__] like
that well it's like anything else he's a
cult leader and there was all this peer
pressure and they're trying to fit in
with all their friends down at the
[__] spawn Ranch I think is what it
was called Ranch yeah and um they had a
couple guy other guys there
they were trying to build a new
civilization and bring about the
apocalypse
Charlie's fantasies see that's I don't I
don't even want to hear any of that
[__] like I said the second somebody
starts talking about that I'm like yep
I'm out they're teenagers I'm out okay
even as a teenager yeah I would not have
I would not have stood for that yeah
intense I'd have just been like nah I'm
just gonna go home and listen records
bye
[Laughter]
but I think that's the only reason and
I'm not saying that most people can't
get sucked into Cults because you
absolutely can but that's probably like
the only reason that I went in a
business because I'm not a joiner and
it's just like as soon as somebody tells
me hey you want to join this I'm like
nope nope it was funny about Charlie is
that he was not even a physically
intimidating dude I think he was [__]
five three or five four skinny weighed
like 130 pounds 120 pounds but evidently
he he had just had a lot of character
and could just Spin A Yarn evidently he
did a live gig with some of the guys
from The Beach Boys The Beach Boys he
said he was great live he could play his
instruments well as some of his uh
recordings have survived yeah they said
we said actually pretty good uh but too
bad that went [__] sideways didn't it
he had problems Manson had fun yeah big
time he had problems I think he might
have had Nazis are bad Charles Manson
had problems I think he I think he
slightly might have been welcome to
understatement Playhouse
some some of his some of what I
recording to him speaking he sounds
slightly schizophrenic
that would explain a lot to be honest
although I have to say that most
schizophrenics are not violent but we
got other people to do it he didn't do
it but yeah that's true I mean hi Dick I
think he did some other [__] like before
the big thing that he got famous for
other crimes but
yeah
Zach is talking about uh operation
midnight climax what I wonder is what
kind of weird [__] the dude's banging
while high try doing and how annoyed the
hookers must have been I'm sure like the
hookers probably had seen it all but
still
yeah that might be kind of a pain in the
ass to like [__] do and I'm sure the
hookers knew that they were being
watched yeah or did they yeah they knew
I mean I guess they probably knew so
it's like one they knew they were being
watched which okay that's one layer of
weird and then two there's like oh I
have to dose these dudes and now they're
like [__] saying it's like you have a
cow head or some [__] like that you know
what I mean
the girls must have thought that this
was had something to do with the cops
yeah I don't think they knew the CIA
maybe they thought it was FBI or cops or
something they just knew they were being
paid to do it to do it and they're just
like yeah whatever and they're like okay
and uh
you know you're dealing with the San
Francisco Bay area if I believe correct
correctly over there near Oakland and um
California San Francisco even back in
these days was [__] up
the girls just had to pay bills you know
I guess they just didn't really
think about it much
girls that get into the sex trade are
not real conscientious you know
it kind of psychos
so uh well like you said or I mean or
they're just like desperate for money
desperate for money but and that's like
the only way they can think of to do it
yeah yeah
just their background didn't cause them
to ask too many questions
maybe yeah well like I said they were
probably used to doing weirder [__] you
know they I'm sure they've probably seen
it all so some like you know spook or
like cop or something like that like
comes to you and says hey we'll give you
money and get out of jail free card
right if you put this [__] in these
dudes drinks and like get them to Yap
afterward and they're just like okay
they may have thought it was gangsters
or something there's no telling what
they thought I would like to find one
but they didn't keep any records and
they didn't keep you right and they
destroyed it I mean yeah they did but
they totally destroyed the records in
the 70s when everything started coming
out about it right because in 1974 the
New York Times like started reporting
about it and around that time they were
like yeah we probably should like shred
all this stuff
they didn't get all of it because they
did find some of it but um but they
shredded almost all of it okay Ultra
stop a lot of those girls probably also
drug addicts probably yeah I mean that's
kind of that's kind of an occupational
usually that's one of the things that
happens that you have to have drug money
so they're not really asking too many
questions Trail
but that's the thing they're probably
intimidated by the guys though yeah they
can get us out of jail yes this is this
is something yeah yeah and I think they
were getting a little bit of money and
[__] like that on the side
and to be honest it's like it was
probably easier work than they were used
to yeah because at least they got like
in a nice brothel nicer situation like
they didn't just have to like [__] dudes
in a car or whatever right or in an
alley right so they're like hey an
actual bed and it's like with a [__]
with Furniture yeah probably that's nice
it's a step up
so they probably like you said they
probably didn't ask too many questions
uh Bryce said yeah in my experience sex
workers are usually pretty much down for
anything yeah I mean I guess they would
have to be like I said that's kind of
like part of the job I guess like you
kind of have to do whatever the dude
pays you to do
which uh you know
kind of we don't have to it's just you
don't have to but you don't know what
will happen if you refuse to no the
girls are desperate they just need the
money that too they need the drug money
or whatever they need money right
so yeah so all of this [__] about
operation midnight Climax and MK Ultra
as a whole started leaking out into the
media in about 1974. like I said I
believe the New York Times the first to
report on it
um but then after that like San
Francisco uh Chronicle like picked up on
it and reported on everything like that
and of course a lot of the public were
sort of outraged because holy [__] like
they're like so the CIA are just like
dosing random people it's like it could
have just been and you know they were
doing other [__] too like without
people's consent and that people were
just like not super happy about it so as
I said um I believe it was Ford in 1975
that actually passed the law about you
know you're not allowed to do like
experimentation on you know people that
aren't consenting and blah blah
um like I said I don't I'm sure that
probably didn't
do anything to like change what they
were doing but I'm sure it made
everybody feel better
um and then in 1977 I think it was
Edward Kennedy that did like uh they did
like a congressional hearing looking
into it so it's like all the dudes
though
they didn't get into any trouble
obviously because by the time all the
[__] came out like George Hunter white I
think he was already dead and Sydney
Gottlieb he didn't get in trouble either
the weird thing about Sydney got Sydney
Gottlieb is that after he retired from
the CIA he went off on a tour and I
don't know if he was trying to like
redeem himself like after the [__] that
he did like throughout his career like
at the CIA but he went totally like off
he went he went into like total hippie
mode he went with his wife and they
lived on this farm and raised goats and
then like they like opened like a
[__] leopard Colony like they went
and [__] like that and he was like all
in environmentalism and like natural
organic foods and all that kind of stuff
it's like he just totally went in that
direction like as an old man which is
kind of [__] crazy so like I said I
don't know if he was just trying to like
I don't know if he felt bad but like
[__] that he did what is it he just
thought that that was gonna like fix it
I don't really know Mr A.D says squeaky
Farms out of prison now yeah that's
right Ah that's right I remember that
she did well she was she 70 something
though now yeah she's got to be an old
lady at this point
their whole lives were wasted on that
[__] [__] it and that's really
sad it's just really sad that it's like
over that dude and I'm not saying that
it's like I don't know if they hadn't
met that dude we talk about and like I
said we talk about this a lot especially
when you talk about like serial killer
couples and stuff I kind of feel like 99
of the time if that chick hadn't met
that dude it probably wouldn't have they
probably would have like turned out like
relatively normal
so it's kind of like sad so I kind of
feel like most of them probably would
have been fine productive citizens if
they hadn't run into his stupid ass you
know what I mean he's dead too isn't he
in Charles Manson dead he's got to be
dead by now right or no is he still
alive I don't even remember
yeah Mr 88 said uh his biggest myth is
Leslie van houten's role she's one of
the Manson three that's still in prison
but she didn't kill Rosemary La Bianca
the jury acknowledged during
deliberations and the coroner confirmed
14 the stab wounds or post-mortem role
of p uh each participant was uh very
different but they're all portrayed as
one in the same yeah Victor said he is
dead I thought he had died yeah I
thought he had when was it it wasn't
that long ago I feel like right but I
remember like hearing about Squeaky from
getting out of jail but I don't remember
like
I don't know I hear so much information
I can't even like [__] processes
anymore you know what I mean it's just
it's just it's too much
but yeah so um
so nobody really knows if this MK Ultra
[__] or something like it is still going
on I suspect it probably is like I said
officially operation of midnight climax
stopped in 1964 when they closed the
last of the safe houses slash brothels
um and that was about when the MK Ultra
project like I said when it started
leaking out in the media and then there
was all these Congressional hearings
about it
you know and the like I said nobody
really got in trouble trouble but
you know some of the government
officials were like hey ACA like knock
that [__] off you're really like
overstepping your bounds and stuff but I
kind of feel like they're probably doing
the same kind of [__] nowadays just
they're a lot more sneaky about it you
know I feel like and they're they're
doing [__] even bigger [__] well yeah
and like I said with AI and internet
stuff right and the thing about it is
that the whole MK Ultra project
what did it really accomplish I mean
other than wasting millions of taxpayer
dollars and dosing a bunch of innocent
people well this part of the AI of the
project that's what you're talking yeah
because we don't really know what the
other parts of MK Ultra were like
yeah I just feel like it didn't really
accomplish much it definitely didn't
accomplish what they were seeking to
accomplish nostensibly which was mind
control they never figured that out no
well not through this means no I think
this is I think
is from what we can see of the parts of
MK Ultra that survived the purge
it looked like grift but that's kind of
standard in a lot of government type
stuff it's grift
but there may have been a few of those
projects that were [__] successful
that weren't griffed because they'll
cast a wide net first to try to find out
what works and then one of them will
work and then they'll focus on that but
in the meantime let's make the grift
yeah they played that for [__] nine
years you said nine ten years nine ten
years yeah
like I said they spent a decade at their
job just going to work every day
drinking martinis sitting on a portable
toilet and watching people [__] I'm
screwing hookers
yeah so
hell of a job man nice work if you can
get it yeah
hell of a job I wouldn't mind that being
my job I don't necessarily want to be
sitting on the toilet I bet you those
guys are gross but [__] those guys are
getting paid the equivalent of like
three or four thousand dollars a month
I'm sure yeah yeah I'm sure they were
making decent money and then had a
budget that they lived on and expense
accounts right yeah that's what I mean
they probably like went to like super
fancy restaurants and [__] like that and
like charged that to CIA it's like yeah
yep oh the American taxiers are picking
up and then they were paying their
[__] rent and then they were here we
need some more we need some more gin and
then partying at the brothel right if
they needed a new coat of paint they
wanted a new refrigerator and [__]
stock the brothel they're just hey all
on the CIA they're probably like buying
the hookers like sexy lingerie yeah yeah
yeah baby I'm gonna get you this and
this okay you come back next week you're
gonna pay for that I'm gonna pay for
that with you here now lean over in
front of the mirror that's right
oh I don't doubt it guys are riding the
great I don't doubt it yeah they kept
that going for a long time right now
each
this is not okay now look
the way these agencies work
the they're compartmentalized
yeah the other people in the CIA didn't
know about this now it's a bunch of
little fiefdoms in this fiefdom that's
the gig that they got going they're
trying to protect that gig they don't
want that gig to go away well yeah I
mean if that was your job you probably
wouldn't want that to go you're like oh
my God this is the best job ever right
so you can't paint all of them with the
same brush because they're not all doing
the same thing right that way if you
catch one of them you can't [__]
torture him and [__] find out what
the other ones are doing you only know
what you're doing
and that it's like that even in the Army
well I mean MK Ultra they even said that
most of the like other CIA people didn't
have any [__] idea I got no idea
where that's going on they didn't write
they were doing so they didn't want to
know right because we're like well we
suspect it's probably bad but yeah and
then they got they got other factions
inside the CIA and it's going to be more
kind of like scholarly [__] and
[__] diplomacy but then you got all
these guys doing this weird [__] here
and probably weirder
I'm thinking that this was just random
it looks weird to us but that was
probably in the middle of the scale
there's probably yeah we're probably
just the tip of the idea yeah it's
probably a lot weirder than that there's
probably all kind of crazy [__] like I
said and I would look at what the
Germans were doing with uh orphans
uh things like female sex operatives
different kinds of sex operatives
chemicals weird weapons
mind control the beginnings of AI they
were probably imagining things like the
internet at that point writing about it
they weren't making it they were just
writing about it probably
yeah like wouldn't it be neat if we had
this
yeah but we have that now yeah now
what's your probably and then how when
this comes what do we do with it they're
writing that [__] like that probably uh
what you have now I would kind of assume
that what they're doing now
is looking at the power of AI
how to get a good grip in big Tech
Industries that are based in English
speaking big Tech Industries
how to use AI to manipulate public
sentiment
to control mass media mind control
through the internet
um
they're probably looking at that they're
probably looking at AI super
intelligence
in other words you have ai that you give
control to the AI of things that
so it can make things that you can't
even imagine basically what I'm talking
about you know you might have ai like
that
um or AI that can
out think enemy AI in terms of like
battle strategy
where to move units and weapons across
the map to of the of the globe
how to get an advantage over
other enemies in the world they're
probably looking at that
um
about I would think that's probably AI
is probably really what they would be
into now
yeah I don't imagine they'd be doing any
of these kind of like little Fields no
but like I said you have to think this
is back in the 50s and 60s when LSD was
really new and the possibilities of it
seemed really intriguing so they're like
oh well maybe this is the miracle drug
we've been looking for so we have to
like you know experiment with all
aspects of this so I get it it was a new
thing that they were exploring but like
I said they wouldn't have to do that
nowadays because obviously everybody
knows they still want mind control oh
yeah they still want that but what they
would do today is they would use a using
AI to get mind control of a population
who uses the internet that's what they
would go for
in other words an AI that filters
filters what you see as an individual
and the information you see on the
internet to get you to come to a
conclusion they want you to have
and to and by that they in that way they
can control you and they couldn't do it
through government agencies they would
do it through private agencies you know
what I mean private big tech companies
you know Twitter YouTube
Google
[__] like that which there's already
evidence that they're involved in all
that
but every nation is involved in the big
Tech Industries of their Nation the
Chinese have the same thing going on
over there with their [__] big tech
companies
social credit score centralized social
credit score stuff
um
vaccine passport [__]
anything to get control over the people
that to make them think what they want
you to think and to get you to obey what
they say mind control
Victor says you just need good narration
and editing on a YouTube video to
convince a conspiracy theorist
especially guys recording in their cars
yeah pretty much
pretty much
um all the Bear in four says Ah that's
what the flat earthers are coming from I
I kind of want to do a show about the
flatters
actually let me write that down I
don't show about them
fascinated by them because I kind of
feel like 90 of them are probably
trolling they're trolling
um
because I know one and they troll well
yeah but I'm just saying that the other
10 I think actually maybe do believe it
yeah
um because I kind of got interested in a
while back and it's like so I was
watching some of the [__] and some of
them do actually seem to like make some
arguments that they seem to think are
compelling even though they aren't
because they don't know anything about
science but they think they do but um
but I'm just kind of interested in one
why anyone would believe that the Earth
was flat one and two it's a battle of
wills and two even if you didn't why
would you bother to troll pretending
that you did like what are you
accomplishing by doing that so I'm like
kind of fascinated by both aspects of
flat earther is it flat earthy is
trolling where did the where did the cap
go from I saw a [__] brilliant video
where somebody is in a [__] airplane
okay proving that the Earth is flat okay
with a [__] you know level a level
with the [__] bubble oh I've seen
that yeah and they're saying you see
normally we'd be going over the crest of
the earth and the bubble would be moving
but the bubble is flat so we're going
forward but see the [__] up thing
about that though is that we laugh at
that but it's like there's some dumbass
rib out there somewhere going oh my God
he's right yeah yeah the force of
gravity is constant on the surface of
the Earth
the bubbles always good so that's what
I'm saying it's like look one it's like
yeah you can say it's like oh nobody's
stupid enough to believe the Earth is
flat wrong uh people are stupid enough
to believe that and it's like I always
like to expect better satellites are
being held up by balloons sure I always
like to expect better people but there
absolutely are like a percentage of
people I don't know how large that
percentage is it's too large in my
estimation but um people that are
absolutely stupid enough to believe that
kind of crap uh well what it is is I
don't think I wouldn't say that they're
stupid what it is is that they have a
vested interest in usually a faith like
Islam or or or
Christianity and you and yeah that
usually helps and those those religions
say that basically describe a flat Earth
well it's the same kind of thing with
creationists it's like most of them
didn't come to creationism right because
that's where the evidence LED them they
came there because they were already
biblical literalists for example and
they're like oh we're just gonna you
know stuff all of the evidence into this
preconceived uh outcome like we already
believe that the Earth is six thousand
years old or whatever so we're just
gonna like contort everything until it
fits into my experience dealing with
them
they know the Earth is round but they
can't admit the Earth is round because
to admit that would open up the
admission of other things that they
don't want to admit right
it has to be a perfect defense so
they're going to start at the very
Basics they're going to [__] argue
that the Earth is flat and they're going
to argue at that
argument that that they're going to
argue at that point in the battlefield
forever
because if they relent there they'll
have to fight somewhere else sure so
they're going to stick with the Flat
Earth but it's trolling if you ask me
they know it's not true
it's just I think the largest percentage
of them know it's a defensive strategy
to protect Christianity in Islam
on one hand Judaism probably too
Orthodox Judaism well just Orthodox
anything normally the Jews don't care
like I don't think normally any kind of
Orthodox well a Christian Orthodox too
flat makes more sense if you read the
Bible flat
and there's a bunch of [__] that they
could point to that you know when Jesus
comes back everybody on the earth sees
him come down from heaven at the same
time well that could only happen on a
flat Earth not a globe like the Earth is
like one big arena big flat Arena
because yeah well it's just got four
corners it's got four corners in the
corners this man he's coming down these
[__] lights and then you got four
corners of the earth and it sits on the
pillars of the Earth but it doesn't say
what the Earth with the pillars are
sitting on so therefore it's flat so
Earth is just like a big tile it's a map
it's a square map sitting on a table and
the table has we live on it and yeah and
you're on it underneath the table
Turtles and above it is a fundament a
dome with stars set in it that move
it's like a light bright yeah the light
like a light bright exactly exactly
that's what they're talking about
which is the silliest [__] ever I mean
it's a you know back then they didn't
know any better like when they wrote the
Bible and they're just like that's what
it looked like to them so that's what
they wrote down to because they didn't
know any better but it's like now
literally the Bible that was the
Septuagint or the [__] the Torah
Bible just includes that so this is
predates the Bible well and actually
probably predates the Torah they're
probably it was probably the uh um
the Mesopotamian view of the Earth
which is the same as the Egyptian view
with the duat and the [__] [__]
Egyptian underworld and the [__]
stars sailing through the oceans of the
night sky and all that you know I mean
they're talking about the ancient
Egyptian model the ancient
uh they're you know Mesopotamian model
of of the earth not Greek the Greeks
knew it was around some of the Romans a
lot of people don't understand that the
Greeks and the Romans knew that the
Earth was a sphere yeah they probably
thought everybody else was idiots yeah
like Jesus they knew the diameter of the
earth yeah they also knew the diameter
of the Earth's orbit around the Sun and
I don't think that women hold on
no no they did not believe in a
heliocentric Earth they thought their
world I think they thought that the
Earth was the center of the universe or
the center of the
solar system I think the Romans and the
Greeks did I think the thought the Earth
was at the center I go back and check
that because they knew about
the weird ellipses of the plant as the
planets would go they'd slow down and
then back up and then go like that they
knew about that
I forgot you guys might know what I'm
talking about I'm too drunk
which kills me that they actually
[__] notice that it's not like that
it's all recorded I mean it's not like
they had anything else to do the answer
Thera mechanism that they found at the
bottom of that [__] ocean and that
ship was basically a calculator a
mechanical computer that computed the
locations of all the [__] um planets
in the moon as they moved through the
Zodiac yeah they had all that [__] so
they knew that about the Motions of the
planet but I but they didn't know that
they were elliptical orbits around the
Sun they didn't see it that way they saw
as the as the Earth in the center and
everything moving around it
but it didn't quite make sense because
of which they would be moving and it
would stop and slow down and then it
would back up a little bit and then it
would go because that's the way it looks
from the surface because we're spinning
yeah during the rotation and they didn't
know that was it Copernicus to figure
that out yeah it was later that there
was elliptical orbits in the middle
yeah in the elliptical orbits because
that took a while I think everybody
thought that they were circular circular
lines with the Earth in the center which
would make more sense yeah but then once
they figured out it was ellipses
ellipses they were like oh okay yeah now
now everything makes sense took him a
long time to figure it out though but I
mean you can't like I said you can't
really blame them because like looking
at [__] it's not super obvious if you
don't
coming from a time like where they lived
it's like just going by observation like
this [__] is not obvious like the way
that [__] works is not obvious so you
can't
like you can't [__] on them for being
stupid too much I mean I can but
I choose not to because like they didn't
know any better they didn't know any
better
um let's see James Perkins said the
whole world could watch something all at
once today because of TV and the
internet you wouldn't have to have a
flat Earth yeah exactly I mean if Jesus
came back today which he's not going to
because he's not real then um yeah we we
could all see it on the internet at the
same time and like I said it would be
just like a big rock concert just to
send out from this guy
if I was Jesus I would totally do like a
whole [__] light show man like he'd
have some [__] lightning and like all
kind of like colored [__] like I said
it's like [__] Fire coming up it'd be
like a whole thing you could do like
whole death metal kind of [__] would be
awesome be awesome he's not gonna do
that though Jesus is no fun like that
but uh yeah so I guess holy [__] it's
like almost quarter to ten
so probably I should wrap this [__] up
because I have to go to bed really soon
yeah go ahead and wrap it up Jim and um
you know because I have to get up very
early in the morning retrograde that's
right yeah yeah yeah yeah he's got it
like I said it does blow my mind that
they noticed that like you would really
have to make very close observations but
like I said it's not like they had TV or
anything else it wasn't just them though
the um the Aztecs and the mines knew
yeah they knew all about that [__] too
and they had a [__] a fantastic
calendar system and an understanding
well they had a good very good records
of the Motions of the planets I don't
they did not have a good
Solar System model though they were just
like the Greeks
Earth in the center they weren't sure
what it was they were looking at they
didn't understand the nature of a planet
you know or a star
they just knew that they moved
I think the entire it's funny because
like the entire history of the human
race has been us getting like further
and further like knock down the peg of
like because like I said at the
beginning it's like it was like oh the
Earth is the center of the universe and
it's like nope actually the sun's the
center of the universe the Earth is just
like out here and we're not even in the
center of the like [__] Galaxy or
nothing we're just like out in the
[__] thing and then like whole like
Charles Darwin comes along and it's like
we're not even the Apex of evolution bro
it's like we're just we just came from
apes and it's like people were just like
freaking out it's like aren't we the
best at anything aren't we special no
we're not special
we're not even really conscious probably
we're probably we have koalia but we're
kind of AI
you just engage with the world
a problem arises you imagine Solutions
and you consistently pick the best
solution you can come up with well
that's just a damn computer program
that's not quite freedom
thought well everybody's best different
parameters that you operate within those
same parameters largely you don't
usually do anything that's like way
outside of your programming the only
thing that's different between an AI
robot and us is that we have qualia we
have a sense of being we feel like we're
here
another thing that a lot of computers
don't have that another thing that a lot
of people do too that maybe they don't
realize even though they think that they
um kind of weigh all their options and
like take the best solution or blah blah
um usually what they'll do is they'll
make the decision based on their
emotions and then rationalize retrograde
like rationalize it yeah afterward like
it'll actually that's usually what
people that's usually on people and it's
done subconsciously by a whole yeah
you're not actually aware of it and it's
a bunch of different facets of your
personality arguing with each other
to come up with that because I mean
usually if you sit there and like try to
rationalize what you're doing it's like
you know what you want to do yeah like
emotionally you know what you want to do
and that's generally what you're gonna
do but then you'll think up like some
good [__] reasons like for why you
did it that way even though that's not
the reason that you did it you did it
because you [__] wanted to yeah
because it felt right that's basically
how that goes but yeah so um
so it's almost 10 o'clock like I said
where we are in Florida yeah so I'm
gonna wrap this up because I have to go
to bed soon yeah because I got to get up
really early in the morning and go to
work
so hopefully you guys have enjoyed the
show like I said I know we already did
one on MK Ultra but I wanted to kind of
concentrate more on uh uh midnight
Climax and like some other [__] that
maybe we didn't talk about on the other
one so hopefully you guys uh enjoyed it
so remember uh to come back on Friday
night at 7 30 p.m Eastern Standard time
for our Sidetrack show which is always
fun we have some drinks and talk about
whatever [__] we want to talk about
there's no topic it's just yeah and
we'll either be going out that night or
not yeah we don't know yet we don't know
but we'll see how we light on cash
me too a little bit
um so we might need to stay in but we've
been buying Jen a whole new wardrobe
well which is good because of our other
projects right yeah which you know I
needed some yeah needed some more
clothing for that yeah give a plug to
[__] give a shout out and plug a
Sheen we got the sheen app and that is a
[__] great app for [__] yeah we
bought like so many cool and you get so
much for 100 bucks I'll buy you like
[__] buy a woman like 20 outfits yeah
I got like I spent 130 and I think I got
like 10 outfits yeah or like 10 dresses
yeah the quality is good yeah they're
all really good all is good yeah it's
crazy yeah it's about like a Hot Topic
but it better design it's more updated
but the quality level is about like well
you would get a Hot Topic yeah back in
the day they charge you 100 bucks back
then got some cool shoes yeah got all
kinds of stuff but yeah so we'll be back
on uh Friday doing the Sidetrack show so
hopefully you guys can join us for that
uh so thanks for dropping by this
evening and thank you for your super
chats and we'll see you guys again on
Friday night good